Ich bin ein sehr großer Mensch.
Und ich bin ein sehr großer Mensch.
Also Mann, aber die Fuffe sind so schön.
Wir gehen mal vor die Tür.
Siehst du, sag ich doch, sag ich doch. Ich heiße Holger Klein, ich drücke hier die Knöpfe. Und bevor wir ins Thema einsteigen, das Thema sind die Big Brother Awards. Kurzer Blick in die Lausitz. Lausitz-Update, meine Freundin wohnt hier an Cottbus. Und die war Sonntagwellen. Und im Kompass wird ja so mit... Andreas im Webblog gelesen und meinte, ja genau, diese blödsinnigen Antworten hab ich auch gekriegt.
Ja.
Das heißt, und hinterher meinte sie dann, als dann hier Frank Schimanski, hieß er glaube ich, der da zum OB gewählt worden ist, mit über 60 Prozent, sagte meine Freundin, die wirklich politisch absolut unverdächtlich ist, also das kann ich mir beim besten Willen nicht vorstellen, dass dieser Mann so viel Stimmen gekriegt hat. Das kann einfach nicht sein. Mit anderen Worten, das Wahlergebnis zur Cottbusse Oberbürgermeisterwahl scheint unter fragwürdigen Umständen zustande gekommen zu sein.
Also zumindestens ist es nicht so zustande gekommen, wie es eigentlich wünschenswert wäre, weil wir haben uns, also das muss man sich auch mal vorstellen, Chaos Computer Club Berlin, die Nerds überhaupt. Also wir haben es tatsächlich geschafft, mit sieben Leuten am Sonntag um halb sieben in Cottbus vor Ort zu sein und haben uns das Ganze mal persönlich angeschaut. Wir haben gesagt, wir sind jetzt die Öffentlichkeit und wir wollen jetzt mal zuschauen.
6.20 Uhr, um nochmal zu betonen.
Ja heul doch. Andere müssen die Zeit schon Asphalt legen.
Aber nicht sonntags.
Was ist mit den Sonntagsasphaltlegern? Okay, können wir weitermachen?
Auf jeden Fall waren die Wahlhelfer vor Ort und die Wahlvorstände, das sind also quasi die Leiter oder die Vorstände des Wahllokals, die waren also doch sehr irritiert. Wir mussten erstmal erklären, telefonieren mit dem zentralen Wahlleitung, mit dem Wahlbüro in Cottbus, dass es auch wirklich geht. Wir mussten also auch wirklich argumentieren, diskutieren, ein bisschen drohen.
Was nennst du irritiert? Also die sind es nicht gewohnt, dass die Bürger ihre Bürgerrechte in Anspruch nehmen?
Nee, schon gar nicht. Und das Besondere bei diesen Computerwahlen ist ja, wenn mit einer Wahlmaschine gewählt wird, das steht auch im Gesetz, dass also nicht nur die Zählung sozusagen, also normalerweise ist ja die Auszählung der Stimmen, wenn also die Urna auf den Tisch gekippt wird, das ist da eigentlich der öffentliche Vorgang bei einer Wahl. Das ist eigentlich spannend, wo die Öffentlichkeit ja auch gefragt ist. Bei diesen Computerwahlen ist aber auch das Wichtige, um zu schauen, dass das ganze Umfeld stimmt. Das heißt also, die öffentliche Wahl beginnt eigentlich schon mit dem Aufbau des Gerätes. Und das wollten wir uns natürlich auch anschauen. Und das haben wir auch gemacht.
Warst du zufrieden damit? Oder wart ihr zufrieden damit?
Naja, also so der Ablauf, das war alles, schien jetzt erstmal keinen besonders verdächtigen Eindruck zu machen. Aber wir hatten keinen einen, also hatten einen Einblick in diese Maschinen. Die wurden dann irgendwann angeliefert. Das heißt, die waren also auch schon da. Möglicherweise, wenn keiner weiß, wo die eigentlich herkamen, wo die gelagert sind, diese Maschinen kamen da an.
Wieso weiß das kein Wort?
Also wir wissen es nicht. Also es wird schon jemand wissen. Aber wir wussten es nicht und es wurde auch nicht gesagt.
Die Kreiswahlleiterin hat auch auf Nachfrage vorher einfach abgelehnt, dazu Statements abzugeben.
Also auf unsere Frage, wann die gekommen sind, ob die jetzt am Abend vorher oder heute Morgen gekommen sind, hieß es nur ganz knapp, kein Kommentar.
Ist sie nicht verpflichtet, das zu sagen?
Wenn sie die Rechtslage nicht kennt, dann können sie einfach am Telefon sagen, nö, sagt sie nicht.
Wenn die Kreiswahlleiterin in Cottbus ist, kennt sie das Wahlgesetz sozusagen nicht.
Das ist natürlich eine schwierige Sache bei dieser Computerwahl, weil es da auch keine Grundsatzurteile zu gibt. Da gibt es das Gesetz und kann man es so oder so auslegen. Wir sind ja auch keine Juristen und hatten aber auch nicht die Möglichkeit. Wir hätten jetzt vor Ort einen Juristen oder einen Anwalt gehabt, der dann sofort zum Gericht geht und sagt, hier stoppt oder sowas. Aber andererseits sind das alles Sachen, die im Nachhinein dazu führen könnten, dass so eine Wahl auch angeworchten werden kann. Das heißt also, Widerspruch eingelegt werden.
Mal eins nach dem anderen. Also ihr seid hingegangen, habt da angerufen, habt gesagt, wo werden denn eigentlich die Wahlmaschinen gelagert? Ist das denn ein sicherer Raum?
Ne, also das hat angefangen damit, dass wir einen Korpus angerufen haben, gefragt haben, wo sind denn überhaupt Wahllokale. Wir würden uns gerne da mal das anschauen. Das gibt es nicht. Es gibt keine Liste mit den Wahllokalen. Wo hast du da angerufen? Es hat jemand von uns bei der zentralen Wahlleitung angerufen.
Also die Kreiswahlleiterin heißt Frau Sabine Hegel. Und die hat auch mehrfach mit uns gesprochen.
Darf die euch die Auskunft über die Wahllokale verweigern?
Also eigentlich ist es so üblich, dass die Wahllokale im Amtsblatt der Stadt veröffentlicht werden. Das machen die anderen Landkreise auch alle so. Nur Cordbus sind offensichtlich die einzigen, wo das nicht so ist. Und deswegen, wir haben zwar dann eine Liste gefunden von einer letzten Bundestagswahl, von der Statistik, vom Statistischen Landesamt, wo die auch verzeichnet waren. Und an das haben wir uns hingehalten. Wir hatten auch Kontakte vor Ort, die uns auch gesagt haben, wo Wahllokale sind. Und wir haben uns in uns ein exemplares Dreistück vorgenommen.
Und da seid ihr hingefahren. Ihr seid morgens reingegangen und habt gesagt, hallo, da sind wir.
Genau, wir waren auch alle alleine. Also da waren keine anderen Cottbuser Bürger, die sich da noch für interessiert hätten. Also in der Wahlgeräteordnung steht ganz klar drin, dass die Inbetriebnahme öffentlich ist. Die Frage ist nur, wann die Inbetriebnahme eigentlich beginnt.
Wenn da Strom eingeschaltet wird, oder?
Na ja, das ist halt die Frage, weil programmiert waren die Maschinen natürlich schon. Die kamen bei den Wahlhelfern an als eine Blackbox. Also sie haben im Prinzip nur noch die Schlüssel rumgedreht und das Gerät angeschaltet. Und das einzig Wichtige für diese Wahlhelfer ist, dass sie mir ungefähr fünfmal gesagt haben, ja sehen Sie mal, hier auf dem Display steht eine Null. Es sind also noch keine Stimmen abgegeben. Das ist so ungefähr das Level an Problemen.
Also für Cottbuser Wahlhelfer ist es ausreichend, dass auf einem Display eine Null steht, um davon auszugehen, dass noch keine Stimme abgegeben wurde?
Und das ist auch alles in Ordnung.
Begreifend, immer ernsthaft. Die begreifen überhaupt nicht, was da los ist.
Es ist auch gar nicht vorgesehen, dass irgendjemand irgendwas ernsthaft kontrolliert. Also es gibt so eine Anleitung, so eine Schritt für Schritt Anleitung, die offensichtlich auch schon schwierig genug ist. Aber da steht irgendwie drinnen, machen Sie jetzt dies, drücken Sie diesen Knopf, drücken Sie, drehen Sie den Schlüssel auf die Stellung und nehmen Sie den Ausdruck, helfen Sie ihm ab und alles ist gut. Also es ist jetzt nicht vorgesehen, dass irgendeine Art von ernsthafter Prüfung da vorgesehen ist. Und auch die Stimmmodule, das sind also die Zählmodule, wo hinterher, das sind also rausnehmbare Module, wie so Speicherkarten, wo diese ganzen Stimmen gespeichert werden, die stecken auch in den Maschinen drin und sind auch nicht besonders versiegelt oder sowas.
Das heißt, das kannst du im Grunde auch austauschen.
Ja, könnte im Prinzip irgendwas drin sein.
Das heißt, könnte im Prinzip haben wir bemerkt, dass dieses Angriffsszenario realistisch geworden ist. Denn die Maschinen wurden angeliefert vor dem Zeitpunkt, wo die Wahlhelfer kamen. Das heißt, sie standen dort alleine in der Schule rum.
Das heißt, wenn die Wahlleiterin die Wahllokale bekannt gegeben hätte, hättet ihr sogar vorher einsteigen und die Module austauschen können, wenn ihr das gewollt hättet.
Es hat einige von unseren Leuten gegeben, die sind alleine mit der Maschine im Wahllokal gewesen und die Wahlläufer trafen erst danach ein und der Hausmeister hatte die Schule aufgeschlossen.
Da fehlen mir jetzt ein bisschen die Worte, obwohl ich im Radio arbeite. Das heißt, das Wahlergebnis ist tatsächlich anzuzweifeln?
Na ja, da geht es uns genauso wie den ganzen Cottbus an.
Wer kann mir denn bitte oder wer kann den Cottbusern garantieren, dass nicht die Leute, die mit der Wahlmaschine alleine im Raum waren, das Modul ausgetauscht haben?
Natürlich niemand. Aber es interessiert die Cottbuser auch gar nicht. Wir haben nämlich umfängliche Umfragen gemacht und das Vertrauen der Cottbuser in diese Maschinen ist unendlich groß. Also bis auf einen Informatiker haben wir genau gar keine Cottbuser Personen den ganzen Tag über gefunden, die, obwohl sie teilweise in der Presse darüber gelesen hatten, irgendein Misstrauen gegen diese Maschinen hatte. Auch wenn sie wissen, dass zu Hause ihre Computer vielleicht nicht immer problemlos funktionieren. Diese Maschinen sind offenbar total vertrauenswürdig.
Aber interessant war auch, dass die Leute, wo wir im Gespräch mit denen waren, natürlich irgendwann ist auch der Groschen gefallen. Die haben gesagt, eigentlich wäre das schon ganz gut, wenn man so etwas nochmal nachzählen könnte.
Ich verkehre jetzt einen reichlichen Cottbus. Ich weiß, dass die Cottbuser ihren Politikern sowieso gar nicht mehr vertrauen, sondern was der Volksmund oder die Straße sagt, dass Cottbus ohnehin regiert wird von einem kleinen Grüppchen irgendwelcher lokaler, mehr oder minder großer Unternehmen, die im Wesentlichen diktieren, was das Rathaus macht. Vielleicht liegt es daran, dass sie überhaupt kein Interesse mehr daran haben. Was siehst du auch in einer Wahlbeteiligung von 40 Prozent, die die hatten?
Das ist aber relativ groß. Ich glaube schon mehr als erwartet. Dafür, dass es eine Oberbürgermeisterwahl war, wo auch nur zwei Personen zur Auswahl standen. Und es war, glaube ich, schon relativ groß, die Wahlbeteiligung.
Da haben die applaudiert, als sie die 40 Prozent Wahlbeteiligung erreicht haben. Da haben die sich echt doll gefreut.
Demokratie scheint selbstverständlich zu werden. Ihr standet jetzt da. Ihr seid da reingegangen und habt gesagt, so, dann zeig mal. Dann habt ihr den ganzen Tag rumgestanden und zugeguckt, wie die Leute auf den Knopf gedrückt haben.
Wie stelle ich mir überhaupt das Setup vor?
Hab ich da auch so eine Wahlkabine, wie mit der Zettelwahl, und dahinter steht dann der Computer?
Ja, genau. Also die Wahl ist der Computer, also die steht sozusagen drauf. Das sind so ein paar Trennwände. Das wird aufgeklappt mit drei Personen. Dann kann man da irgendwie ran und mit Schnappschlössern und so weiter. Dann wird das Ding aufgebaut. Und dann ist in der Kabine drin quasi ein Display, eine kleine Anzeige, wo dann nochmal die gewählte Partei oder die gewählte Person angezeigt wird. Und dann neben einem Bestätigungsklopf. Und dann schicke ich das Ganze ab. Das ist sozusagen wieder ein Wurf in die Urne.
Und das geht dann auf das Modul, das ihr möglicherweise ausgetauscht habt, als ihr alleine mit den Löhren im Ding war?
Was denkbar gewesen wäre, oder jemand, der das angetan hat.
Ich sag ja, möglicherweise habt ihr das ausgetauscht. Wird ja nie jemand erfahren.
Denkbar, ja.
Dazu möchten wir vielleicht jetzt keinen Kommentar haben. Es sollen jetzt Leute, die vielleicht den Corpus zuhören, gerade die Kratze kriegen über die Vorstellung, dass ihr das vielleicht wirklich ausgetauscht habt.
Die richtig große Kratze kriege ich eigentlich bei etwas anderem. Nämlich, dass uns auch noch verweigert wurde, dass wir die nachjährige Auszählung, die man ja eigentlich nicht Auszählung nennen kann, auch nicht beobachten dürfen. Das heißt, 18.03 Uhr waren die Maschinen eingeklappt, ins Auto verladen und werden zum Zentralwahlbüro gefahren. Und wir durften sozusagen nicht daran teilnehmen, wie die Stimmmodule ausgelesen werden. Also Frau Hickel hat schon...
Also das ist praktisch die Zettelauszählung beim normalen Wahllokal, wo sie auf der CDU, SPD, alles auf der anderen Seite...
Die ist öffentlich, na selbstverständlich.
Also wir wurden von den Wahllokalen, wo wir waren, da ist uns dann mit ein bisschen Argumentieren und Nachfragen und Drohnen auch gelungen, die Ergebnisse zu bekommen, die von der Maschine ausgedruckt worden sind. Also das ist halt das, was, da kommen dann wir aus der Kasse, aus dem Kassendrucker, so ein Bon raus. Und da stehen dann die ganzen gezählten Stimmen drauf. Dann wird immer verglichen, ob das in der Gesamtsumme übereinstimmt mit den Wählern, die da hingegangen sind.
Das wird dann auch noch auf dem Papier abgehakt.
Das machen dann die Wahlhelfer, machen das, genau. Und dann kommt dieses Wahlmodul, dieses Zählmodul, kommt dann in einen Papierumschlag rein, Siegel drauf, draufgeklebt und weg damit. Also ab zur zentralen Zählstelle.
Wer fährt das dahin?
Also in meinem Wahlbüro, wo ich war, mit ihrem Privat-Pkw.
Und ja, da verschwindet es denn da und wird da offensichtlich ausgezählt. Da gibt es eine zentrale Stelle, wo nochmal ein Lesegerät ist. Und dann werden dann draus quasi in Echtzeit sozusagen, also Stimmenbezirk für Stimmenbezirk, werden die dann ausgelesen. Und dann ist quasi um 19 Uhr schon vorläufiges Endergebnis.
Genau. Und Frau Hickel hat schon am Telefon als Zumut gefunden, dass wir sie überhaupt danach gefragt haben, dass wir an diesem Auslesen der Stimmmodule gerne teilnehmen wollen.
Da hat aber dann auch die Cottbuser-Wahlleiterin ein bisschen Probleme mit ihrem Demokratieverständnis.
Naja, die hat natürlich sowieso insgesamt eine schwere Zeit, also weil zum einen war diese Wahl schon im Vorfeld ein bisschen kompliziert, also von der politischen Situation, von der Vorbereitung der Kandidaten und so was.
Ich habe immer davon aus, dass sie verbeamtet ist, dass sie mit diesem ganzen Filz nichts zu tun hat zunächst mal.
Ja, ich glaube, die ist Ministerin sogar.
Die hat einfach mal ihren Job zu machen.
Und dann ist natürlich, also die hat natürlich durch diese ganze Geschichte mit der Firma, die da Schwierigkeiten hat, weil die Veröffentlichung der Holländer ja gerade auch in die Vorbereitung der Wahl gefallen ist. Man muss sich das so vorstellen, die Frau kommt aus dem Urlaub zurück, im Monat der Früh und hat irgendwie fünf oder zehn Anrufe von Journalisten, ob dann jetzt die Wahl abgesagt wird wegen den Wahlmaschinen oder wegen den Wahlcomputern. Und insofern hat sie dann mit Sicherheit auch eine schwere Zeit gehabt. Und es wäre nun wirklich auch echt blöd gewesen, sage ich mal für Cottbus oder für sie, wenn jetzt das Ministerium kurzfristig die Zulassung für die Wahlcomputer entzogen hätte. Das ist ja schon ein denkbares Szenario auch. Es hätte passieren können.
Es hätte passieren müssen, würde ich so anhören, was er erzählt.
Das ist übrigens die Gleichstellungsbeauftragte.
Die ist auch gleichzeitig für die Wahlen verantwortlich.
Das Problem dabei ist, dass die Zulassung dieser Wahlcomputer für die Wahl, dafür gibt es bestimmte Auflagen. Da gibt es also ein bestimmtes Prozedere, was eingehalten werden muss.
Vollkommen egal, ihr wart alleine mit den Dingern im Wahllokal und habt die Module ausgetauscht.
Nicht in einen Wahllokal.
Ja gut, aber in einigen.
Also es hätte bei einem Wahllokal tatsächlich realistische Möglichkeiten.
Das reicht mir, um anzuzweifeln, dass diese Wahl überhaupt in irgendeiner Form rechtmäßig war. Also wenn ich der Cottbusse Oberbürgermeister Schimanski wäre, würde ich das als einen zweifelhaften Sieg ansehen, oder nicht?
Das ist eigentlich nicht der Punkt. Der Punkt ist, dass wir schon gar nicht wissen, wie die Prozedur davor zustande gekommen ist. Diese Black Boxes standen ja da bereits.
Davon mal ganz abgesehen. Da bist du ja schon auf einer Metaebene der Betrachtung.
Das ist aber die eigentliche Manipulationsmöglichkeit. Man muss ja davon ausgehen, dass der Täter, der so eine Wahl manipulieren will, ein Innen-Täter ist. Also ein jemand, der wiedergewählt werden möchte. Der hatte zehn Tage Zeit, weil so alt waren die Kassenbongs, diese Maschinen zu manipulieren. Wir wissen nichts, weil niemand war dabei.
Also insgesamt ist es schwierig. Wir denken, dass die zuständigen Ministerien da auf jeden Fall noch mal drüber nachdenken sollten. Es gibt ja auch mittlerweile eine Online-Petition.
Warte mal, was macht Cottbus jetzt? Also wir können ja von hier aus nicht die Wahl irgendwie an Zweifel anfangen.
Nein, das können nur Cottbuser.
Ja, das können das nicht, aber die Cottbuser können das.
Ist das schwierig? Oder ein formloser Brief?
Man kann einen Widerspruch einlegen, aber wenn man ihn natürlich gut begründet, dann hätte er wenigstens mehr Chancen. Es gab aber in Deutschland noch keinen Fall.
Würdet ihr dabei helfen, den Widerspruch gut zu begründen? Wenn jetzt eine Cottbuserin zuhört und sagt, ich würde das gerne machen, ich finde das alles sehr heikel, ich möchte nicht, dass die Demokratie so verkommt, wie das in Cottbus gerade passiert zu sein scheint.
Wir haben natürlich Cottbuser, die mit uns bereits Kontakt aufgenommen haben, mehrere. Das Problem ist, unsere Kompetenz ist technischer Art und nicht juristischer Art. Wir könnten das wohl begründen, ob es juristisch wasserfest wäre, steht auf dem anderen Blatt.
Aber ich denke, wir können es auf jeden Fall vermitteln. Das letzte Mal war der Ulrich Wiesner hier. Vielleicht wäre der der geeignete Ansprechpartner.
Ihm werden wir auf jeden Fall helfen, weil Ulrich Wiesner geht ja gegen diese Wahlgeräte auf Bundesebene vor. Und da hoffen wir auch, dass diese Sache vor Ort im Bundesverfassungsgericht geht.
Tja, und damit sind wir bei der Online-Petition.
Es gibt eine Online-Petition. Das heißt, man kann online dagegen unterschreiben.
Vielleicht wissen die Leute noch nicht mal oder nicht alle Leute, dass es so etwas wie den Petitionsausschuss beim Bundestag gibt. Das heißt, da kann man Eingaben hinrichten, wenn man der Meinung ist, dass irgendwelche Gesetze geändert, abgeschafft oder geschaffen werden sollen. Und hoffen, dass sich der Bundestag damit befasst. Richtig.
Und da gibt es eine, die ist jetzt, da ist die Liste, die Unterschriftenliste schon groß am Wachsen. Das ist über www.bundestag.de zu erreichen und da unter Petitionen, unter Online-Petitionen. Und da kann also jeder Bürger ab 18, ab 16, ab 16 unterschreiben oder sozusagen seinen Namen, seine Identität hinterlassen. Und dann wird es aufgenommen. Wir hoffen, dass wir vielleicht sogar 40.000 erreichen. Im Moment sind wir, glaube ich, bei so knapp 12.000.
Ja, wir schaffen 50.000 und wir haben einen Link auf ccc.de.
Warum wollen wir 40.000 erreichen?
Wir wollen 50.000 erreichen, weil offenbar die Stimmenanzahl spielt eine Rolle, in welcher Weise das bürokratisch abgearbeitet wird.
Je mehr Leute unterschreiben, desto wichtiger erscheint es dann auch den Mitarbeitern im Bundestag.
Genau. Also auf ccc.de ist ein Link, da braucht man nur draufklicken.
Und nicht wundern, der Weg führt zu einer britischen Uni?
Schottland sitzt in dem.
Schottland, nicht wundern, das ist schon okay. Das liegt einfach daran, dass es ein Pilotprojekt ist. Und da sieht die Seite genauso aus. Also es geht nicht darum, dass jemand Adressen abgreifen will, sondern es ist wirklich eine richtig offizielle Sache. Und man kann damit gut im Gewissen seine Daten hinterlassen.
Wenn wir also diese 50.000 Stimmen schaffen, dann würde es eine direkte Anhörung geben. Das ist auch nicht zu verhindern. Und genau die wollen wir schaffen.
Wer würde dann da stehen und angehört werden?
Ich bin nicht ganz sicher, wie die Prozedur läuft, aber dann gibt es eine Anhörung und zwar auf jeden Fall.
Ach so, verstehe. Das heißt, es kann dann nicht mehr unter den Tisch gekehrt werden sozusagen? Nee, ganz genau. Wo ist die nächste Wahl, um die wir uns kümmern müssten? Auch wir Journalisten vielleicht. Offensichtlich ist das ja bei der Mainstream-Journalie noch gar nicht wirklich angekommen.
Das Problem ist, es spritzt noch kein Blut. Also es ist so ein bisschen schwierig, noch so ein bisschen wenig greifbar. Und dadurch, dass die Wahlen immer so weit weg sind und gerade bei den Regionalwahlen ja auch immer nur einen kleinen Bereich betreffen, ist es schwierig. Die Holländer haben es ein bisschen einfacher. Die haben jetzt recht große Wahlen und da wird das Ganze auch ein bisschen höher aufgehangen. Aber ich denke mal, auch in Deutschland ist das ein Thema, was breit diskutiert werden sollte, wie weit diese Wahlcomputer, vor allem auch geeignet sind, das Vertrauen in die Demokratie weiter zu schädigen.
Die Wahlcomputer waren das Thema im vergangenen Chaos Radio, Chaos Radio 117. Ein Link dahin, auch zum Podcast, um es euch nochmal anzuhören, wenn ihr es verpasst haben solltet, findet ihr auf www.chaosradio.com. Die Wahl im Cottbus ist gelaufen. Vielleicht will ja der eine oder andere sie anzweifeln. Und wie heißt das?
Anfechten?
Anfechten. Vielleicht aber auch nicht. Dann beschwert euch hinterher auch nicht, wenn sie euch die Bürgerrechte noch weiter aushöhlen. Kommen wir zu unserem eigentlichen Thema in Chaos Radio 118. Heute geht es um die Big Brother Awards. Ich würde sagen, wir machen eine Motto-Musik, dann Nachrichten und dann steigen wir ein.
Super. Vorratsdaten-Speicherung, Swift-Datenübermittlung, Terrorismusbekämpfungsgesetz, präventive Telekommunikations- und Postüberwachung, Rasterfahndung, Satellitenüberwachung, Kfz-Kennzeichenerfassung, biometrische Ausweise, BND-Skandale, Fluggastdaten...
Wir wollen die Fahndung weiter perfektionieren, indem wir Verdachtsurapie alle kontrollieren.
Auch mit elektronischer Datenverleihung.
Auch mit elektronischer Datenverleihung, dass wir eben nicht willkürliche Kontrollen machen. Und jetzt sag ich das mal salopp. Diejenigen kontrollieren, die so ausschauen, als ob sie eine Kontrolle dringend bedürfen.
Sowas gibt's.
Kontrolle muss natürlich sein. Kontrolle, Kontrolle, Kontrolle muss natürlich sein. Kontrolle, Kontrolle.
Die Menschen erwarten von uns natürlich eine Antwort.
Ob die Daten geeignet wären, die Täter zu fassen, weiß kein Mensch.
Wir würden die Gefahr unterschätzen und nicht aus notwendigem Ton um den Menschen zu schützen.
Wir wollen die Fondung weiter perfektionieren.
Indem wir Verdachtsrouten alle kontrollieren. Auch mit elektronischer Datenvereinbarung.
Indem wir Verdachtsrouten alle kontrollieren.
Auch nach diesem Kompromiss wird es möglich sein, über Monate hinweg minutiös nachzuvollziehen, wer wo im Internet gesurft hat, wer wann mit wem per Telefon, Handy oder E-Mail kommuniziert hat, wer wann welche Online-Dienste in Anspruch genommen hat. Das ist gespeichert. Das soll von allen gespeichert werden. Und nicht nur in einem gezielten Verfahren.
Konkret bedeutet, dass Gieberschät unter Überwachung der Telekommunikation nur so nah wie gesagt, ob die Daten geeignet wären, in die Erde zu fassen, weiß kein Mensch.
Kann ich nur sagen, äh, da drüben.
Wir haben die Fibotrophie des Staates maulich genug erlebt. Wir hatten nun bei uns in Deutschland den mit falschem Pratos verklebten und in privitiven Desch-Machs-Santismus von Bormen realisierenden totalitären Staat. Und den im Hintergrund haben wir in das Grundgesetz erneut gelegt, das Bekenntnis zu Menschenrecht und Verbraucherschutz.
Man kann Freiheit nicht sichern, in die man Recht abbaut. Staat ist nicht der Staat, bei dem der Zweck den Mittel heiligt. Staat ist der Staat der inneren Gewissheit. Das heißt, der Gewissheit darüber, dass die Menschen und die Bürgerrechte und deren Beachtung noch immer die besten Garanten der inneren Sicherheit sind. Recht sichert Freiheit.
Sie müssen sich darüber klar werden, dass Sie nicht an der Grundlage unserer Demokratie herumdoktern können, wie es Ihnen gerade beliebt.
Sowas gibt's.
Wir wollen die Ordnung so nah wie es war, in dem wir verdacht oder brühen. Alle kontrollieren.
Namen von 1983 bis 86. Drei Alben in Berlin. Auf. Und zwar in den Hansa Studios in Kreuzberg. Und die könnt ihr euch jetzt angucken. Fritz Music Tours Berlin. Auf den Spuren der Popmusikgeschichte Berlins. Mit dem Bus durch die Stadt. Jetzt auch als Special. Die Fritz Music Tour durch die legendären Hansa Studios. Fritz Music Tours Berlin.
Mehr Infos Fritz.de.
Fritz.
Und das hört man um halb 11.
Der mutmaßliche Feuer von Totenschendung durch Bundeswehrsoldaten in Afghanistan sorgt in Deutschland parteiübergreifend für Empörung. Bundeskanzlerin Merkel sprach von einem schockierenden und abscheulichen Vorfall.
Verteidigungsminister Jung können.
Und.
Das. Das Bundeskabinett hat die umstrittene Gesundheitsreform beschlossen. Ministerin Schmidt bezeichnete den Gesetzentwurf als großen Fortschritt für das Gesundheitswesen. Undurchschaubare Bürokratie werde abgebaut. In einer gemeinsamen Erklärung protestierten dagegen erneut mehrere Interessenverbände des Gesundheitswesens gegen die Reform. Der Brandenburger Landtag hat das Versammlungsgesetz geändert. Damit sollen Neonazi-Aufmärscher an Gedenkstätten und auf dem größten deutschen Soldatenfriedhof in Halbe verhindert werden. Auch in diesem Jahr hatten Rechtsextremisten anlässlich des Volkstrauertages im November wieder eine Demonstration in Halbe angekündigt. Und noch zum Sportvizemeister Alba Berlin hat die Siegesserie in der Basketball-Bundesliga fortgesetzt. In einem vorgezogenen Punktspiel bezwang Alba neuling Paderborn Basket mit 92 zu 77. Nachts Richtung Prignitz aufkommende Bewölkung, aber kaum Regen, bei Temperaturen zwischen 7 und 12 Grad. Und morgen dann neben Wolkenfeldern heiter und trocken. Und das Ganze bei 19 bis 24 Grad. Wir haben keine aktuellen Meldungen der Polizei. Weiter eine gute Fahrt.
Vielen Dank Matthias.
Fritz ist eine Produktion des RBB.
Und wenn im Radio 103, 1, dann Fritz in der Prignitz.
Chaosradio 118, der Blue Moon mit dem Chaos Computer Club. Constanze, Frank und Holger im Studio und unser Thema sind die Big Brother Awards. Willst du uns die Awards sagen? Ja, ich mach mal Musik.
Die Big Brother Awards sind ein Negativ-Datenschutz-Preis. Das heißt also, das ist eine Auszeichnung für Firmen, Institutionen, Behörden, Politiker, Innenminister...
Gibt es eigentlich irgendeinen Innenminister, der mal unzweifelhaft ist?
Ja, in den 40er- 50er- und 60er-Jahren.
Das muss vor den Zeiten des Big Brother Awards gewesen sein.
Vor den 40er-Jahren, Constanze, ja.
Da war die Welt noch nicht mehr.
Wir besprechen uns dann noch, ne?
Gibt seit 2000, da ist der erste Preis verliehen worden. Der Chaos Computer Club ist zusammen mit anderen Bürgerrechtsorganisationen in der Jury vertreten. Das heißt also, wir sind da vielleicht so ein bisschen für die eher technischen Themen, würde ich mal sagen. Wobei wir natürlich auch immer, so wie wir halt sind, übergreifen, die ganzen Sachen angucken, jetzt nicht nur in die technischen Details reinschauen, sondern uns schon auch für die Auswirkungen des Gesamten interessieren. Und es gab auch dieses Jahr wieder jede Menge Preisträger, sechs Preisträger. Interessant war dieses Jahr, also zum einen ist es so, dass die Anzahl der Nominierungen, also das, was uns die Leute zuschicken an Vorschlägen, würde also jedes Jahr mehr werden. Es verdoppelt sich fast jedes Jahr ungefähr. Also das ist schon richtig, es ist so auf dem Tisch gestapelt, so gut 20 Zentimeter Papier mittlerweile, was da so an Eingaben kommt. Also teilweise auch mit Vorrecherchen schon, je nachdem wie umfangreich die Sachen sind, die uns die Leute schicken. Also den gibt es halt einen, der schreibt nur irgendwie, nehmt Schily, der hat es verdient oder so, oder die GEZ. So klar ist es halt, aber auch schon so Dauerpreisträger. Das Interessante war diesmal, dass die Leute sehr viel Politik und Behörden vorgeschlagen haben. Also das ist eine Veränderung im Gegensatz zu den vergangenen Jahren. Da war es so, dass tendenziell eher Wirtschaft, Unternehmen vorgeschlagen worden sind. Und der Trend geht jetzt aber eindeutig wieder dazu, dass eine Bedrohung oder ja, soll ich sagen, schon eine Bedrohung eigentlich eher durch Staat, Behörden gesehen wird. Und da sind also viel, viel mehr Sachen nominiert worden als letztes Jahr im Vergleich.
Ist die Bedrohung durch Behörden denn auch gewachsen oder ist es nur eine Wahrnehmungsverschiebung der Leute?
Also wir haben natürlich schon durch die ganzen, Anführungszeichen an, die Terrormaßnahmen, sind natürlich eine ganze Menge Sachen verabschiedet worden oder in der Mache, die ganz doll auch in den privaten Lebensbereich eingreifen. Also das ist ja auch eine neue Qualität von Überwachung, von Eingriff in die Privatsphäre, die wir da jetzt erleben. Insofern denke ich mal, ist es schon berechtigt, dass auch die ordentlich Preise kriegen, wobei natürlich die Wirtschaft da jetzt auch nicht besser wird in dem Sinne. Nur da ist man vielleicht schon ein bisschen abgehärteter. Es ist ja auch nicht so, dass die Vorschläge weniger werden, nur verschieben sich halt die Verhältnisse.
Ich denke, dass ja auch alle letzten Beschlüsse, die von Seiten der Regierung gefasst wurden, doch durch die Medien jetzt besser kommentiert werden. Zwar nicht immer so kritisch, wie wir uns das wünschen, aber zumindest was den E-Pass betrifft oder jetzt die Vorratsdatenspeicherung, zumindest kann man was darüber lesen, die Leute empfinden das als Bedrohung.
Genau, und wir wollen heute eigentlich mal die Preisträger vorstellen. Das heißt, wir hatten am letzten Freitag die Big Brother Awards, die Gala sozusagen, wo also offiziell die Preise verkündet worden sind. Die Preisträger. Leider ist wieder niemand erschienen, um den Preis abzuholen. Da war bisher...
Schneid haben die alle nicht, das trauen sie sich nicht. Dieses Foto, das wäre doch mal ein Foto, was man auch sehen möchte, wie der Innenminister nimmt den Preis entgegen.
Ich muss sagen, die Firma Microsoft waren bisher in der Geschichte der Big Brother Awards, der deutschen Big Brother Awards, die einzigen, die sich wirklich haben nicht nehmen lassen, auch zu kommen. Die haben also ihren gerade neu frisch angestellten Datenschutzbeauftragten für Microsoft Deutschland hingeschickt, zwar sozusagen seine erste Amtshandlung war uns aufzutauchen, aber er hat sich wirklich gut geschlagen, muss ich sagen. Es war einfach ein professioneller Auftritt, er ist gekommen, hat sozusagen Reue gezeigt, er hat gezeigt, ja ja, und wissen wir, und wir versuchen uns zu ändern. Und dann mögen wir jetzt Leute widersprechen, aber ich glaube schon, dass das Thema Privacy, also Datenschutz, Privatsphäre, bei Microsoft jetzt zumindest in ein anderes Bewusstsein gerückt ist mittlerweile. Ob wir da jetzt mit unserem Preis dran schuld sind, weiß ich nicht, aber zumindestens ist es halt der Trend, also ich weiß von einer Kollegin aus der Jury, dass es also bei Microsoft schon jetzt auch Anweisungen gibt, neue Technologien auch auf so Sachen hin zu überprüfen.
Ich meine, es ist mittlerweile für manche Unternehmen ein Werbeargument, dass sie sagen, okay, wir gehen mit unseren Daten eben anders um. Wir sind keine, wir machen keine Datenverbrechen.
Dummerweise gibt es bei Politikern keinen Wettbewerb.
Ja, und von euch wollen wir wissen, wer sind denn eure Kandidaten? Wen würdet ihr nominieren? Wem würdet ihr so einen Negativpreis zukommen lassen? Was hat euch besonders geärgert? Was glaubt ihr, welche Firma ist besonders sorglos mit vielleicht Kundendaten, mit euren Daten umgegangen oder spitzet seinen Kunden hinterher, schnüffelt ihn hinterher? Welches Amt hätte diesen Preis verdient? Welche Behörde, welcher Politiker auch? Wobei wir uns da ganz gern auf Deutschland konzentrieren würden. Mein klarer Busch kriegt auch einen Lifetime-Award, keine Frage. Busch ist immer ein Argument.
Die werden auch gerade Evel, oder?
Ja, das schwenkt wohl gerade auf die Evel-Side.
Wo holen wir uns denn jetzt die guten E-Mail-Adressen hin? 0331 70 97 110 ist die Nummer der Fritzotline. Ihr seid herzlich eingeladen, eure Big Brother Award-Nominis zu nominieren. Anzusagen? Ihr wisst schon, 0331 70 97 110. Wer hätte denn eurer Meinung nach einen Big Brother Award verdient, hat vielleicht noch keinen bekommen oder hat schon einen bekommen und sollte ruhig noch mal einen kriegen? Wie viele hat Payback?
Na, es gibt immer nur einen pro Firma.
Die haben aber schon einen.
Also sind schon genug Einreichungen, dass man da jedes Jahr ein paar andere nehmen kann.
Da bin ich mir mal gespannt, ob die Höhenden auch dieser Meinung sind. 0331 70 97 110 Wer hätte denn einen Big Brother Award verdient, weil er mit euren Daten ja einfach mal saumäßig umgeht oder gar nicht?
Der Big Brother Award in der Kategorie Politik 1 geht an dir. Mitglieder des vierten Landtags von Mecklenburg-Vorpommern, vertreten durch die Landtagspräsidentin Sylvia Wettschneider, für die gesetzliche Erlaubnis zum Abhören und zur Tonaufzeichnung an öffentlichen Plätzen, in öffentlichen Gebäuden und in öffentlichen Verkehrsmitteln.
Gibt es da irgendwie ein paar mehr Details dazu?
Na klar, es war also Alva Freude, der mit uns in der Jury sitzt. Und der hat also den Preis verkündet, sozusagen an den Landtag von Mecklenburg-Vorpommern. Und was die gemacht haben, ist eine ganz, ganz große Sauerei, fast nicht, also eher eine Dummheit. Weil ich habe also wirklich erhebliche Zweifel, dass das Ganze Bestand hat vor dem Verfassungsgericht. Es geht also darum, es ist eine präventive, also ohne Anlass, eine Videoüberwachung und Audioüberwachung von öffentlichen Plätzen beschlossen worden.
Da kann man aber Kunst machen mit...
Also, Entschuldigung, wir haben erst mal......Mikrofurzen oder...
Ja, so, das weißte ich gar nicht, das ist nicht auffällig.
Genau. Also von öffentlichen Plätzen und Gebäuden, also im Prinzip alles, was nicht privat ist sozusagen. Und man muss sich das auch wirklich vorstellen. Das heißt also, die Polizei kann mit einem Mikrofon uns hinterherspionieren. Also Video ist ja schon schlimm genug an sich, aber die legen jetzt noch einen drauf und sagen, okay, wir wollen jetzt auch noch mithören, was also die Terroristen in Schwerin im Park, auf der Parkbank für Attentate blasen.
Was denn für Terroristen? Der Punkt ist, die schnorcheln einfach mal jeden ab. Verdachtsunabhängig. Verdachtsunabhängig.
Auch wenn du keinen Bart hast?
Auch wenn du keinen Bart hast.
Was ist mit Frauen, die einen Bart haben?
Auch die werden abgeschnorchelt.
Das ist furchtbar.
Wer hat geklagt?
Noch keiner, das ist ja ganz frisch. Wir hoffen natürlich, dass da besorgte Bürger und Schwerin möglicherweise dagegen vorgehen.
Besorgte Bürger wie die Fritzsörer. Ihr seid eingeladen anzurufen unter 0331 77 97 110 zu sagen, wer eurer Meinung nach einen Big Brother Award verdient hat. Wir hatten dieses Gesetz überhaupt durchgedrückt in Mecklenburg vor?
Du meinst, welche Parteien das geschlossen haben. Da müssen wir jetzt mal in die Zusammensetzung gucken.
Das war das rote, rote Bündnis.
Das ist wirklich eine Dummheit. Weil die Frage, die ich gerade stellen wollte, lautet, haben die noch alle Tassen im Schrank?
Nein, man erwartet eigentlich das eher von den Konservativen. Das ist schon wahr. Da wundert man sich, dass der Rot-Rote-Landtag durchaus auch mal die Schili-Schiene fahren kann.
Ja, gut. Ich weiß nur, damals, 1998 auf dem Kongress, hat Frank Rieger gesagt, jetzt haben wir das Problem. Früher bei den Schwarzen, da wussten wir wenigstens mal ganz klar, wer evil ist, bei den Roten.
Ich finde, wir haben auch sehr bewegliche Feindbilder mittlerweile, also da wird es immer so eine Gruppe von Menschen, die man eben gerade so durch die Pressezert genommen und wenn es jetzt die Kofferbomber sind, also die Gruppe von Menschen, die da reinfallen oder eben die Hooligans zur WM, das momentane Feindbild ändert sich eben. Und wenn man einfach mal alle abschneuchelt, dann hat man das Problem immer gleich gelöst.
Ja, aber es kommt ja immer wieder ein neues dazu. Ah ne, dann ja nicht mehr, da hat man sie ja längst gehabt. 0331 70 97 1 1 0, wer hätte einen Big Brother Award verdient? Daniel aus Koblenz.
Ja, also da fällt mir jetzt spontan eigentlich, ich würde eigentlich sagen, ich wollte Lidl vorschlagen. Ja, das ist jetzt schon länger her. Ich habe mal irgendwann auf Telepolis einen Bericht gelesen, dass Lidl halt eben hingeht und seine Mitarbeiter teilweise während der Arbeit Video überwacht und dass sie also damals auch, die haben, dass sie auch hingehen und ihre Mitarbeiter in Arbeitsverträgen, dass sie die Arbeitsverträge halt teilweise so schreiben, dass die Mitarbeiter sozusagen fast dazu genötigt werden, also auch ihr Privatleben irgendwie so voll nach dem, so auszurichten, dass halt immer leistungsfähig sind und das, also wie das damals bei Walmart war, das glaube ich ja auch mal eine Zeit lang.
Ja, ja, das kam auch bei Lidl auf, dass also der private Umgang teilweise verboten wurde mit den Mitarbeitern untereinander.
Sind die mal nominiert worden schon, Frank?
Die haben vorletztes Jahr den Preis bekommen.
Die haben vorletztes Jahr sogar den Preis bekommen.
Wo du jetzt direkt nachfragst, nee, also Lidl war es schon, aber es ist schon richtig, eigentlich hätten sie mal wieder einen verdient.
Das hat sich vor allen Dingen nicht viel geändert, trotz der ganzen Presse, trotz der Sache mit dem Buch, was dann noch rauskam.
Das war das Schwarzbuch Lidl von Verdi, sehr zu empfehlen.
Ja und dann fällt mir halt eben noch zum Beispiel ein Saturn, würde ich auch noch vorschlagen. Weil? Weil, also bei uns in Koblenz gibt es halt eben so ein größeres, sag ich jetzt mal, so ein Shopping-Mall und da ist eine Filiale von Saturn drinnen und die haben zum Beispiel ihre Kameras, ist mir das letzte Mal aufgefallen, auch so aufgehangen, dass sie, wenn man an der Kasse die Geheimzahl, wenn man mit ET-Karte bezahlt.
Das macht Media Markt übrigens auch.
Dass die die Kameras halt so aufgehangen haben, dass man halt sehen kann, wenn die Leute jetzt die Hand nicht beim Eingeben der Geheimnummer, die Hand drüber halten, dass man dann halt eben die Geheimzahl sehen kann, die eingetippt worden ist.
Das ist mir, das ist mir in, ich weiß, bis auf einen, in allen Media-Märkten schon aufgefallen.
Und der zweite Punkt ist, den jetzt, der mir bei Saturn jetzt auch aufgefallen ist, ist, dass die halt an der Kasse einfach fragen, aus welchem Postleitzahlgebiet man kommt.
Da sag ich ja immer die Postfach-Postleitzahl von Fritz.
Ich sag immer, wie ist denn ihre?
Ja, ich geh dann immer hin und tu halt eben ganz schamlos Lügen.
Um die Ergebnisse insgesamt zu verfälschen, ja?
Ja gut, weil ich schätze mal, die werden wohl die Daten halt eben dann auch benutzen, um einen halt, um einen Werbung irgendwie so zu schicken, die dann halt auf ihr...
Die wollen wissen, was sie für ein Einzugsgebiet haben.
Ja, denke ich auch.
Wo sie den nächsten Markt aufmachen.
Genau. Ich finde es lohnt sich, wenn man zumindest mal Zeit hat, die Verkäufer da ruhig mal in eine Diskussion zu wickeln. In der Regel habe ich bei mir selbst den Effekt bemerkt, dass die hinter mir stehen und dann dieselben Fragen stellen, was ich mir besonders toll finde. Das mache ich übrigens auch bei Personenkontrollen. Das ist immer sehr spannend. Ich bitte Sie denn, ob ich erst in Ihre Tasche gucken darf, bevor Sie in meine gucken.
Echt?
Ja gut, aber ich habe die Erfahrung gemacht, ich gehe dann ja auch ab und an schon mal hin und sage dann, ja, können Sie mir mal den Datenschutzbeauftragten holen. Und ich habe jetzt zum Beispiel bei Saturn, als ich dann gesagt habe, ja, hier, da hängen die Kameras, die überwachen die Leute während der Arbeit und gucken hier. Da hat er mir dann einfach gesagt, ja, dann gehen Sie woanders hineinkaufen.
Na ja, sollte dir schon klar sein, was du zu sagen als Kunde Ihnen wert bist. Da sollte man vielleicht auch Konsequenzen ziehen.
Ja gut, ich habe ihm dann halt gesagt, gut, dann gebe ich mein Geld halt woanders aus und kaufe meine CD-Holinge in Zukunft halt eben, keine Ahnung, in irgendeinem kleinen Laden oder so.
Wo es ja sowieso billiger ist, wie kürzlich die Stiftung Warentest rausgefunden wurde.
Ja, genau.
Nur 30 Prozent, glaube ich, waren das alle Angebote. Bei Media Markt und Saturn sind wirklich billiger als bei der Konkurrenz.
Aber in der Werbung, da sagen die doch.
Wir sind die Guten, die tun immer so, als wäre es billig.
Ja gut, aber man muss halt so unterscheiden auch. Also Werbung ist ja, sag ich mal, halt eben Werbung. Also es weiß ja fast fast jeder eigentlich, dass das, was in der Werbung irgendwie gesagt hat, sowieso immer ein bisschen übertrieben ist.
Warum haben die Läden dann so viel Erfolg, wenn das fast jeder weiß?
Die Läden haben wahrscheinlich, also ist jetzt so, hab ich mir jetzt meist so, meine Theorie, die haben deswegen einfach so viel Erfolg, weil sie halt eben so viel Werbung machen.
Ja, aber wenn die Leute doch wissen, dass die Werbung gelogen ist.
Ja gut, vielleicht hinterfragen die Leute das zu wenig.
Sind alles Cottbusser Wähler.
Ja, vielleicht sind sie auch alle NPD-Wähler, man weiß es ja nicht.
Also wir halten fest, Lidl, Saturn.
Ja, und dann würde mir noch einfallen das Arbeitsamt.
Das Arbeitsamt?
Auch eine gute Idee.
Und zwar ganz einfach aus dem Grund, weil die ja jetzt, die haben ja jetzt nicht mehr diese Räume, wo man, wenn man jetzt zum Beispiel einen Hartz-IV-Antrag stellen muss, haben die ja nicht mehr diese Räume, wo man halt reingehen muss und so eine Nummer ziehen muss, sondern die haben ja jetzt so ein, ich weiß nicht, wie die das bei uns nennen, die das Kunden-Terminal. Also das ist ein eigengroßer Raum, da stehen fünf bis zehn Schreibtische an jedem Schreibtisch und Sachbearbeiter.
Aber sind die nicht so abgetrennt mit so zu trennen Wänden?
Nein, die sind nicht abgetrennt. So und es ist ja dann so, wenn ich jetzt, sag ich mal, heutzutage einen Hartz-IV-Antrag stellen muss, muss ich ja teilweise wirklich meine gesamten Vermögens, was weiß ich was, mein ganzes Vermögen offenlegen und meine Daten und so. So und also es war jetzt bei mir so, wie ich jetzt nach Koblenz umgezogen bin, muss ich mich dann ja ummelden gehen und da war dann halt neben mir am Schreibtisch einer gewesen, der hat dann so ein Hartz-IV-Antrag abgegeben und ich hätte eigentlich nur hingehen müssen und hätte mir aufschreiben müssen, wo der wohnt, wie viel Geld der irgendwie verdient, das habe ich alles mitgekriegt.
Also du hättest dir gerne ein bisschen mehr Privathit da gewünscht.
Ja, auf jeden Fall, weil das ja so, sag ich mal, mit den Hartz-IV-Anträgen finde ich ja sowieso schon ziemlich krass, dass man halt eben alles offenlegen muss, das ist ja an sich, sag ich mal, jetzt schon von dem ganzen System, wie die Daten überhaupt bearbeitet werden, sowieso schon, finde ich, ziemlich bedenklich.
Bist du da auch schon mal angerufen worden? Es gab doch mal diese Telefonaktion vom Arbeitsamt jetzt.
Nee, also angerufen haben die mich noch nicht. Ich meine, ich muss jetzt aber auch dazu sagen, ich bin jemand, der hingegangen ist, ich habe mich nicht ins Telefonbuch eintragen lassen.
Nee, also die rufen schon die Leute an und wollen sozusagen nochmal versuchen, die Leute dann quasi, sag ich mal, Widersprüche oder sowas zu verwickeln.
Ach echt?
Sie fragen die Daten ab, die dort abmachen jetzt auch schon.
Ja gut, also wie gesagt, ja gut und ich bin dann natürlich, wie ich dann in dem Amt gewesen bin, bin ich dann auch hingegangen und habe dann so gesagt, ja, können Sie mir mal den Datenschutzbeauftragten holen und der kam dann auch wirklich und ich hab dem dann gesagt, ja, ich fände es halt ziemlich bedenklich, dass ich mich hier einfach reinsetzen kann und kann mir hier die Daten von Sozialhilfeempfängern oder so holen und da hat er mir gesagt, das wäre auf Anraten von einer Unternehmensberatung gemacht worden.
Das ist wahrscheinlich wiederholen, Unternehmensberatung, welche könnte das gewesen sein?
Da haben die Konsultants gesagt, das ist schon gut so, das lassen wir so.
Ich meine, es wäre irgendwie Kempinski oder so gewesen.
Fast.
Kempinski?
Ja genau, McKinsey war es.
War das nicht Berger?
Nein, das war McKinsey.
Bestimmen haben die da mehrere. Das ist wirklich ein großes Projekt, wo sie viele mehr machen.
Es gibt unendlich viele Beispiele, wo Daten irgendwo erfasst werden, was ich meine, es ist im Moment sowieso Trend, generell überhaupt überall Daten zu sammeln und auszuwerten.
Ja, wir haben das jetzt auch mitgeschnitten, inklusive deiner Telefonnummer, Daniel.
Also wir haben deine drei Kandidaten in unsere Vorschlagsliste aufgenommen.
0331 70 97 110. Wem würdet ihr gerne einen Big Brother Award verliehen sehen oder auch mehrere? Der Big Brother Award ist ein Negativ-Preis, der verliehen wird an Leute, die mit Privatsphäre nachlässig bis gleich grüßen.
Das sind sogenannte Datenverbrecher.
Datenverbrecher, die zu Daten, die da ringen, gehören.
Datenterroristen. Bärtige Datenterroristen, die ja in Schmuck-Vorpommern überwacht werden. 0331 77 97 110. Wer ist dein Kandidat?
Mein Kandidat ist die Hovo G. Ich wohne in Hohenscheinhausen, diese Wohnungsbaugesellschaft oder Gesellschaft ist das glaube ich.
Ja, ja, ist eine Wohnungsbaugenossenschaft. Ne, Gesellschaft, ja.
Die sind da noch Zeit dabei, ihre ganzen Fahrstühle mit Kameras auszustatten.
Echt?
Ja, mit der Begründung halt, Wandalismus und so.
Natürlich, welche Begründung sonst?
Ja, wirklich, von einem Fall, von einem, der ist geistig behindert und der ist halt auch recht laut. Und dem wurde jetzt die Wohnung gekündigt mit der Begründung, er hätte da Randaliert.
Im Fahrstuhl?
Nein, hat er nicht. Wir sagen doch, unser Fahrstuhl hat auch wieder unsere Kamera aus dem Fahrstuhl. Die war ja auch auf seine Tücher gerichtet.
Na, ist das nur eine Kamera oder gibt es auch ein System, dass man die Menschen im Fahrstuhl damit ansprechen kann? Also sagen kann, hey, benimm dich.
Ja, das haben sie ja sowieso, dieses Notrufsystem. Also denke ich mal, da werden sie sicherlich auch die Menschen ansprechen können, ne? Also wenn ihr jetzt denken werdet, kannste ja da drücken und da meldet sich ja auch so ein...
Na, ist ja jetzt sozusagen sehr trendy, dass man die Kameras auch mit einer Ausrüstung herstellt, die gleichzeitig erlauben, dass man halt sagt, hey, also du machst dir was falsch mit...
Instinkt Maßregelung.
Ja, war mir auch oft gefallen, ich habe mal meine Hand vor die Kamera, da hat es angefangen zu tuten.
Nicht?
Geil, da sitzen da tatsächlich Leute vor, gucken zu, offensichtlich.
Wahrscheinlich wird das manuell ausgelöst gewesen sein.
Ja, da kann man sich doch mal den Spaß geben, beim Einsteigen schon mal einen Aufkleber drauf zu backen und die dann mal hupen lassen, bis sie schwarz werden.
Aber gut, den Vorschlag werden wir mal aufnehmen. So, alle Fahrstühle einer ganzen Wohnungsbaugesellschaft mit Videokamerasausrüstung finde ich auch schon entschuldigen.
Also vor allem der Fahrstuhl ist jetzt... Ich meine, okay, also Vandalismus denke ich mal, sehe ich ein, das ist ein Problem. Aber andererseits ist der Fahrstuhl natürlich auch genau der Moment, wo man jetzt irgendwo zu Besuch geht, also wenn man jetzt in ein Geschäft irgendwo reinfährt, Büro oder sowas, wo man sich noch mal irgendwie ein bisschen zurechtdrücken, Eier richten, was auch immer irgendwie machen kann und...
Also und Frauen schminken sich im Fahrstuhl und was man nicht noch halt im Fahrstuhl machen kann.
Doch klar, dann tut es bestimmt wieder.
Okay, die HOVO-G.
Ist das... Warte mal, ist das in allen Häusern der HOVO-G? Weißt du das? Da müssen wir doch mal vorbei und Spaß haben.
Man müsste sich vor allen Dingen mal überlegen, welche Kosten so ein Projekt sicherlich verschlingt. Und was sie mit dem Geld eigentlich machen könnten, erinnert mich an diese ganze Ausstattung von Schulen mit Videokameras. Also da geben die echt Millionen für aus. Da können die viele Lehrer viele Jahre anstellen und die stecken dann einfach an diese Videokameras. Und dann beschweren sich nachher die Lehrer darüber, dass sie niemanden haben, der sich diese Aufzeichnung überhaupt mal ansieht, weil die Lehrer haben so schon genug zu tun. Also so an diese Projekte erinnert mich das auch.
Vielleicht haben die dieselbe Unternehmensberatung wie die HOVO G. Vielen Dank Frank. 0331 70 97 110 im Chaosradio ist die Frage, wem würdet ihr denn einen Big Brother Award verleihen, dürftet ihr es verleihen? Christoph aus Leipzig.
Hallo. Und zwar, ich bin an der Leipziger Uni und die haben die tolle Idee, die Uni komplett mit Kameras zu überwachen.
Hm, in Leipzig.
Ja, und zwar nicht nur irgendwie so jetzt die IT-Zimmer und so, sondern halt auch die Hörsäle und die...
Lass mich raten, weil zu viele Beamer geklaut werden?
Na ja, so offensichtlich...
Oder aus Angst vor internationalem Terrorismus?
Der hat internationaler, bärtiger Terrorismus.
Der Kanzler hat ein tolles Statement dazu abgelassen.
Nämlich?
Die Videoüberwachung soll der bessere Kommunikation zwischen Lehrenden und Hausmeister dienen, wenn etwa Probleme mit der Technik ausgehen.
Das war aber die gleiche Begründung wie in der Humboldt-Uni, oder? Dann hast du das ein bisschen mitbekommen.
Was in der Humboldt-Uni?
Da ging es darum, dass die Vortragenden, glaube ich, der Technik, wenn das Mikrofon vorne zu leise war, automatisch...
Genau, da wurden auch in der Art diese Gründe vorgeschoben. Da gab es auch einen sehr langen Streit. In der Regel ist es in der Humboldt-Uni, hier in Berlin, jetzt so, dass die Kameras kippt, aber die laufen nicht. Die meisten wurden einfach nicht mehr abgemacht von den Plätzen. Die laufen aber nicht.
Ach so, ich dachte, das wäre so wie... Der Vater von einer Freundin ist Zahnarzt, und der hat so im Aufgang zu seiner Praxis einfach so ein Dummy. Der hängt da, ich dachte, so was wäre jetzt zu abschrecken.
Na klar, die sind im Prinzip Dummies.
Das soll dann so ein abschreckendes Beispiel sein, oder?
Ja, das ist in Frankfurt.
Im Grunde hat eine Attrappe dieselbe Wirkung wie eine Videokamera. Die Leute fühlen sich beobachtet, und insofern hat es keine große andere Wirkung als eine tatsächlich laufende Videokamera.
Nur die Jungs, die von diesen Sicherheitsdiensten in den Kabuffen sitzen, die langweilen sich dann, wenn da kein Bild kommt.
Bleibt Spaß.
Die Frage ist überhaupt, ob das die ganze Zeit jemand anschaut.
Ja, wobei, da denke ich mal, ist die Diskussion auch mittlerweile zumindest bei uns im Chaos Computer Club ein bisschen weiter. Und dass wir sagen, also das ist gar nicht mehr das Argument. Also sagen ja viele, ach ja, ist immer noch egal, wenn überall Kameras hängen, es guckt sich ja eh keiner an. Das Problem ist aber, dass die elektronische Bildverarbeitung und Signalverarbeitung mittlerweile deutlich besser wird. Das heißt also diese ganzen Szenarien Bewegungserkennung, Gestik, Mimik, Wohlaufgleich, Gesichtserkennung, die Sachen werden besser und sie werden irgendwann funktionieren. Und dann haben wir ein Problem, wenn nämlich nicht mehr Menschen, die Menschen beobachten, sondern Maschinen, die Menschen beobachten.
Und auch noch die gespeicherten Daten, weil oft meinst du dir so, dass es nicht nur das Band ist, was gerade läuft, sondern dass es erstmal auch gespeichert wird.
Und das Problem ist, das Szenario ist ganz einfach, die Maschinen werden dann irgendwann Alarm schlagen, wenn sich jemand nicht standardkonform verhält. Und dann ist natürlich die logische Folge, dass die Menschen alles versuchen, um irgendwelchen Unangenehmlichkeiten auf dem Parkplatz, im Fahrstuhl oder aus dem Weg zu gehen. Und sich dann einfach so verhalten, dass die Maschinen bitte keinen Alarm mehr schlagen. Ich meine, das ist ein Szenario, das muss man sich mal vorstellen.
Heinz, der aufzuhupt.
Das ist im Prinzip auch, was Sie jetzt in Mainz an diesem Bahnhof gerade testen, wo Sie also dieses Kamerasystem aufgebaut haben und versuchen, die Menschen, die in Mainz über diesen Bahnhof gehen, automatisch zu detiktieren.
Ich bin morgen in Frankfurt, da hüpfe ich mal rüber nach Mainz und benehme mich auffällig.
Gibt es da schon Daten, wie erfolgreich diese Erkennung ist?
Aber du kannst nicht jetzt sagen, es wird ein großer Erfolg werden.
Sie haben halt die Testpersonen unter etwas schwierigen Bedingungen, weil Sie nicht so einfach Testpersonen für dieses Pilotprojekt gefunden haben. Sie haben sie vorher in einen Datenbank gepackt. Und was das Gesichtserkennungssystem momentan versucht, ist diese Menschen herauszufinden unter den vielen Menschen, die da so lang gehen. Tagsüber.
Warum, Frank, warum wird es erfolgreich sein?
Mit anderen Worten, man kann dann so irgendwelche Verbrecher beobachten, die jetzt einen Tag in der Datenbank haben.
Genau. Und sagen, die zur Fahndung ausgeschrieben sind, dann auch zu erkennen.
Dann ist man in beides Fall verdächtigt, wenn man mal irgendwo bei einer Demo hat.
Ja, also es geht jetzt darum, mehrere Systeme zu vergleichen. Es sind also mehrere Systeme parallel installiert. Und dann will man schauen, wie hoch ist die Quote, die Erkennungsquote und die Fehlerquote. Aber die Erfahrung mit solchen Projekten zeigt uns, dass auch wenn es noch so schlecht gelaufen ist, die Zahlen noch so im Boden sind, es wird ein großer Erfolg sein. Das haben wir jetzt beim E-Pass erlebt. Und es wird auch bei anderen Biomiebetriebprojekten so sein. Sagen wir noch eine Frage zur Uni. Wie weit sind da die Pläne eigentlich? Wie konkret ist denn das?
Also es wird ja im Moment bei uns alles neu gebaut. Und die Planungen beziehen sich hauptsächlich auf die Neubauten. Aber es ist halt so, dass wir schon 86 Kameras auf dem gesamten Campus haben.
Das ist ja besser als der Big Brother Container.
Also das ist schon gut verteilt. Wobei man sagen muss, die Leipziger Uni, die ist sehr weit über die Stadt verbreitet. Man hat da immer mal so einzelne Gebäude. Also es ist jetzt nicht ein großes Gebiet. Und von daher, ja, nicht so gewaltig. Aber es ist trotzdem halt 86 Stück.
Hat sich denn da eure studentische Selbstverwaltung ein bisschen drum gekümmert? Und eine Uni hat ja standardmäßig auch einen Datenschutzbeauftragten. Wie ist das denn mit dem? Hat der sich dann mal zu Wort gemeldet? Na, ich hoffe doch. Da sollte man aber dringend mal mit in die Diskussion reinholen, wenn er es nur nicht getan hat.
Datenschutzbeauftragte, also die sind doch auch nur wortgewaltig, aber absolut handlungsunfähig oder nicht? Man kann doch nicht in jedem Fall sagen... Wenn ich mir angucke, was der Bundesdatenschutzbeauftragte zum Beispiel immer abgewatscht wird von irgendwelchen und welchen drittklassigen Innenministern, was der sich gefallen lassen muss... Ja, aber er wird hier nicht gehört. Also Schily davor, jetzt Schäuble, die können machen, was sie wollen. Wenn der Datenschutzbeauftragte sagt, hier, das finde ich nicht in Ordnung, dann kriegt er einen Rüffel nach dem Motto, du hast mich nicht zu belehren, du kleine Wurst.
Hat der überhaupt irgendwelche Rechte?
Dann können wir den Datenschutzbeauftragten auch streichen.
Na ja, der hat eine beratende Funktion, mehr hat er natürlich auch nicht. Aber ich glaube, das Problem dahinter ist größer. Also das eigentliche Problem ist doch, dass die Gesellschaft, in der wir leben, hier mehrheitlich lieber Sicherheit als Freiheit wäre. Wir müssen also zu sagen, erst mal daran arbeiten, was die Menschen denken. Also weil sie wollen ja diese Sicherheit. Wenn man ihnen sagt, oh, dieses System bringt Sicherheit, dann freuen sie sich. Und daran muss man arbeiten. Eben, daran genau diese Aufklärung muss man leisten.
Wir bemühen uns. Danke Christoph.
Danke.
Danke. Das ist Chaosradio 118 im Blumen auf Fritz am letzten Mittwoch im Monat. Die Big Brother Awards sind unser Thema heute Abend.
Meine Damen und Herren, der Big Brother Award 2006 in der Kategorie Verwaltung geht an die Kultusministerkonferenz der Länder. Für das vollständige Ignorieren der Amtsschimmel würde sagen die fehlende Berücksichtigung von Datenschutzanforderungen beim Versuch bundesweit einheitliche, lebenslange Schüler-IDs einzuführen. Von der Wiege bis zur Bare, zumindest aber bis zum ersten Job oder der Entlassung in die Arbeitslosigkeit sollen allen Schülerinnen und Schülern von allgemeinbildenden und beruflichen Schulen sowie von Schulen des Gesundheitswesens und in Zukunft möglichst auch der Vorschulen und in der Erwachsenenbildung eine eindeutige und einmalige Kennnummer erhalten, unter der in Zukunft ihr vollständiges Bildungsprofil angelegt werden soll. Zu erfassen sind neben Geschlecht und Geburtsdatum unter anderem auch Angaben über Muttersprache und Staatsangehörigkeit, Konfession, die Schule und den besuchten Unterricht, Förderschwerpunkte, also auffällige Defizite in bestimmten Lernbereichen und ob jemand Spätaussiedler oder Migrantin ist.
Und das war am besten RFID implantiert, ne?
Ja, das war Karin Schula, die hat die Laudatio gehalten für die Kultusministerkonferenz. Das ist eine Sache, die sogar immerhin so ein bisschen durch die Medien gegangen ist. Sogar auch das Fernsehen hat darüber berichtet. Es geht also darum, dass alle Schüler auf ihrem gesamten Bildungsweg eine lebenslange einheitliche Kennnummer bekommen.
Ich meine, die Kultusministerkonferenz an sich ist ja schon mal völlig grotesk, aber das...
Man muss sich ja noch mal überlegen, welche Daten tatsächlich bei den Schulbehörden dann gespeichert werden. Ihr kennt den aktuellen Fall, wo zum Beispiel bei dem Kind ein ADS-Syndrom diagnostiziert wurde, kommt natürlich in die Schülerakte, weil man muss ja dem Schüler speziell helfen. Das heißt, er hat auch, wenn er das vielleicht nur für einen gewissen Zeitraum hat, bis zu seinem Schulende diesen ADS-Flag.
Darüber hinaus ja auch, weil wenn ich mich irgendwo bewerbe, wird natürlich der Arbeitgeber erst mal bei der Schule nachfragen, ob er nicht den Datensatz haben kann und wird dann erkennen, dass ich zwischenzeitlich mal auffällig war und vielleicht ein bisschen zu laut nach Mitbestimmung gerufen habe oder so.
Das ist natürlich noch eine ganz andere Sache. Also das Problem sind ja auch immer die Begehrlichkeiten, das heißt, wenn diese Daten erst mal erfasst sind, die sind zentral erfasst. Also das eine Problem dabei ist überhaupt diese zentrale ID. Also es gibt ja einen guten Grund, warum wir in Deutschland keine zentrale Personenkennziffer haben. Das heißt also, wir haben gesagt nach den Erfahrungen aus dem Dritten Reich, es ist manchmal eben nicht wünschenswert, wenn Personen wirklich direkt eindeutig Register gestützt über eine Kennziffer zu identifizieren sind. Das ist eine Sache, das wollen wir nicht, weil das macht bestimmte Schreckenszenarien noch viel, viel einfacher zu realisieren. Und deswegen wollen wir möglichst alle Daten dezentral haben. Das heißt, man hat bei einer Behörde da registriert und bei der anderen Behörde so registriert, aber es soll eben nicht diese zentrale Datenbanknummer haben, was natürlich auch eine Degradierung der Persönlichkeit ist. Das heißt, wenn ich als Schüler nicht mehr Frank-Rosengard bin, sondern 53472-B, das ist natürlich noch mal eine ganz andere Klasse, wie ich mich auch als Mensch dabei fühle.
Und hinzu kommt, dass ja eigentlich dieses Verbot der zentralen Datenhaltung auch auf einer anderen Ebene immer mehr unterlaufen wird. Also wir sehen es halt auf der Verwaltungsebene momentan, wo aus Effizienzgründen und auch Kostengründen heraus argumentiert wird, sodass man also nicht mehr einsieht, warum diese Daten dann auf 16 Bundesländer verteilt gehalten werden. Also dass sich vor allen Dingen auch im europäischen Rahmen die ganzen Verwaltungsinformatiker darüber beschweren, dass das doch alles Unsinn sei und das würde doch nur teuer sein und ineffizient. Und mit dem Kostenargument kann man da zum einen kommen und zum anderen natürlich, wenn man denn mal jemand sucht, einen bösen Verbrecher, dann würde man es mit einer zentralen Datenhaltung viel einfacher haben. Und deshalb ist ja momentan der Plan, hier eine initiierte Suche zu machen, die einer zentralen Personenkennzahl gleichkäme.
Gibt es irgendjemanden, der soweit denkt oder sich mal überlegt hat, was passieren könnte, wenn die Rechtsradikalen jetzt weiter die Wahlen gewinnen und gleichzeitig diese Datensammelei weitergeht? Also wenn irgendwann mal angenommen, wir würden von der NPD regiert und die Daten, die die Gesundheitskarte und jetzt die Kultusministerkonferenz erheben wollen, wären alle erhoben.
Ach Gott, die NPD, wir haben jetzt Wahlcomputer, die NPD wird marginal werden.
Da haben wir noch mal Glück gehabt, Wahlcomputer gegen rechts.
Wir manipulieren die auf linke Wahlergebnisse, das ist ja total klar.
Das ist so geil, 0331 70 97 110, wem würdet ihr gerne ein Big Brother Award verleihen? Konrad aus Berlin.
Ich würde gerne den Deutschen Posten Award verleihen.
Der Post. Jumi.
Ich muss dazu ein bisschen ausholen, meine Oma, die wurde vor, es ist bestimmt schon ein halbes, dreiviertel Jahr her, da wurde die angerufen und da wurde über Telefon halt Werbung gemacht, also, oder wurde so irgendwas gefragt, so vom Call Center und solche Geschichten. Und meine Oma fand das total zum Kotzen, also die ist da so ein bisschen konservativ, die mag sowas überhaupt nicht.
Die ist da ein bisschen konservativ?
Wo hat denn ihr meine Nummer her und all sowas? Und die hat, und die Adresse, die hat ja auch so Zeug zugeschickt bekommen und so. Und da hat sie nach mehrmaligen Anfragen und so, hat sie mitbekommen, oder hat ihr diese Person gesagt, dass die Telefonnummer und die Adresse von der Deutschen Post ausgegeben wurde, dass sie die von der Deutschen Post haben. Und meine Oma hat natürlich total ruskiert, wie das sein kann. Und da wurde sie wohl aufgeklärt, dass es Firmen gibt, die machen eine Anfrage bei der Deutschen Post, wie es aussieht, ob sie Adresse oder Telefonnummer haben können. Und die Deutsche Post verkauft die dann quasi an diese Firmen und sagt, ok, pass auf, so und so viel, und dann kriegt die halt so und so die Adressen davon hin. Und die da dazien schicken.
Genau.
Ich finde, das ist ja eine Frechheit hoch zehn. Also, oder so.
Es gibt die Deutsche Post Adress GmbH. Das ist eine Tochterfirma der Deutschen Post. Und die ist für diese ganzen Datenschiebereien und auch Adresswäsche ist ein schöner Begriff, der dafür geprägt wurde.
Adresswäsche?
Also das ist das eine. Und zum anderen ist es so, dass man quasi über angeschlossene Partnerunternehmen, also über so klein gedruckte, kaum lesbare Einwilligungen auf irgendwelchen Preisausschreiben und auch Verträgen, Bestellgeschichten, immer so ein bisschen irgendwas einwilligt. Und um den Weg zu verschleiern, werden diese Daten durch die gewisse Dienstleister durchgeschoben. Das heißt, die werden dann wandern in so einem großen Topf, werden ein bisschen umgerührt, korrigiert, noch abgeglichen, ob sie stimmen und kommen dann irgendwo hinten wieder raus. Und dadurch ist aber im Prinzip nicht mehr nachzuvollziehen, wo die eigentlich herkommen. Das heißt also, wenn ich jetzt wirklich als Kunde nachfragen will, wer hat jetzt eigentlich meine Daten weitergegeben, dann kann ich mir eigentlich erstmal eine Woche Urlaub nehmen.
Ich meine, wenn ich mir das mal überlege, meine Oma, die hätte bestimmt einen Schrieb weggeworfen oder so. Also ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass sie da irgendwie eine Wille hat. Höchstens vielleicht gegenüber der Post oder so, wo sie da mal eine Wille hat, wenn sie irgendwelche Adressen oder so, einen Schrieb von denen gehabt hat oder so. Aber so von irgendwelchen anderen Unternehmen, sowas pfeffert die immer gleich weg. Also ich habe schon einen schönen Schluck, als ich das gehört habe.
Die Deutsche Post hat im Jahr 2002 einen Big Brother Award bekommen, und zwar für ihre Nachsendeanträge, weil die wirklich sehr penetrant waren, was das Nachfragen angeht, ob man denn wirklich nicht damit einverstanden ist, dass man die Daten jetzt weiter verwendet und weiter gibt an andere Firmen. Und haben dann nochmal gefragt, ob sie sich auch wirklich ganz sicher sind. Und dann muss dann also nochmal wieder, also sogenanntes Double-Opt-Out, das ist der Fachbegriff dafür, wo man also wirklich absagen und nochmal bestätigen muss. Und das war also dann ein bisschen too much. Und das Interessante ist, ich habe mir mal den Spaß gemacht, mal nachzufragen auf dem Postamt, wenn ich jetzt den Nachsender antrage, ob die Daten dann auch an die GEZ weitergegeben werden. Ja, selbstverständlich, das können Sie aber da durchstreichen, aber dann müssen Sie damit rechnen, dass die Posten immer so ein bisschen verzögert bekommen.
Wenn die das nicht an die GEZ verkaufen dürfen, dann kriegst du später deine Briefe.
Das war so eine Ansage, das war lustigerweise mit einem Reporter, aber es war halt leider auch versteckt aufgenommen, sofern nicht verwendbar.
Also die Sache mit der deutschen Post ist echt schon über viele Jahre bekannt. Und da das natürlich auch ein gutes Geld ist, wird sie damit verdienen. Warum sollten sie das einstellen? Sie haben ja diese extra Gesellschaft gegründet, das ist ja nicht illegal in dem Sinne. Es ist halt ein klassischer Adresshändler, sicherlich nicht einer der größten in Deutschland, aber wir werden schon gut verdienen damit.
Es gibt noch größere Adresshändler als die Post?
Ja, na, Shoba. Also in Deutschland ist die größte Firma wohl Shoba.
Ja, ich glaube, die beiden teilen sich in ersten Platz.
Na gut, okay, dann kann sein, aber...
Also sie haben so ein bisschen ihre Fachgebiete und sowas.
Was kosten denn eigentlich so Adressen?
Das ist abhängig davon, welchen Größenordnung man hat bestellt. Also die zu zahlende Summe pro Adresse sinkt natürlich mit der Anzahl der zu bestellenden Adressen, die man gerne hätte. Und wenn man sie noch vorsortiert haben möchte, sozusagen nach Alter oder sozialem Scoring, dann ändern sich die Preise. Man kann nicht sagen, dass eine Adresse irgendwie 4 Cent kostet oder so, sondern man muss dann schon sehen, welche Qualität die Daten haben. Die von der Post haben in der Regel eine sehr hohe Qualität, weil korrigierte Daten teurer sind. Diesen Trick, den viele Menschen verwenden, dass sie wegen ihren Vornamen etwas falsch schreiben oder so, dergleichen funktioniert dann nicht, weil die werden einfach gereinigt von diesem angeblichen Typus.
Kann ich da eigentlich auch privat mir Adressen zuschicken lassen, also ohne dass ich ein Unternehmen bin? Du könntest jetzt rein theoretisch sagen, ok, Passt auf, ich will jetzt so und so viele Adressen haben.
Privatadressen aller Bundestagsabgeordneten.
Ja, du kannst ja Adressen kaufen.
Ich weiß nicht, also ich kann da nur den Kopf schütteln.
Ich finde das auch krass, aber die meisten Leute, also die wissen das einfach schlicht nicht.
Kann ich die Privatadressen aller Bundestagsabgeordneten?
Irgendwie ihren guten Ruf dadurch ausfinden, ich. Also ich finde, das ist schon...
Ja, rufen.
Aber könnte ich die Privatadressen aller Bundestagsabgeordneten kaufen?
Die sind vielleicht geschützt.
Ich könnte mir auch vorstellen, dass Landtags- und Bundestagsabgeordneten da einen gewissen Schutz genießen.
Schade, weil dann könnte man nämlich wirklich mal anfangen, Mailings zu machen. Aber das ist einfach mal so hier, das habt ihr uns eingebrochen.
Also ich finde ja ihre Fingerabdrücke viel interessanter.
Bundestagsabgeordneten-Fingerabdrücke, die kriegt ihr ja auf dem Bundestagsklo.
Ja, geht da täglich hin.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, es würde mich auch nicht wundern, wenn da nicht schon Leute fleißig sammeln würden. Würde dich auch nicht wundern, Frank, ne?
Also wir haben es aufgenommen in die Liste.
0331 70 97 110. Wen habt ihr denn dabei ertappt, dass er mit Daten, mit Privatsphäre äußerst sorglos umgeht, ja gar ein Datenverbrecher ist, einen Big Brother Award verdient hat. Die Big Brother Awards sind verliehen worden am vergangenen Freitag in Bielefeld. Und wir legen heute noch ein Schippchen drauf, bzw. ihr seid eingeladen, noch ein Schippchen drauf zu legen. 0331 70 97 110. Frank, Rausch, Rausch, Rausch, Rausch.
Frank?
Kannst du irgendwie langsamer fahren oder sowas, dass es nicht ganz so rauscht?
Mache ich schon, mache ich schon.
Wer hat dann von dir einen Preis verdient?
Ich wollte mich äußern zu dem anderen Frank, der anrufen hatte zu dieser Hubo EG mit dieser Fahrstuhlüberwachung.
Ah, die Hubo EG.
Ja, ich finde es ja nicht so verkehrt, weil wenn ich mir die Fahrstühle angucke, wie die aussehen, ist es mitunter schlimm.
Also du findest, dass die Videoüberwachung schon gerechtfertigt ist, weil stets die Fahrstühle so schlimm aussehen.
Wenn sie jetzt weggebunden ist, ist diese Videoüberwachung, finde ich sie ja nicht schlecht. Ich meine, ich bin da ein Mieter und wenn die da Kosten haben, da permanent neue Stiegel einzubauen, diese Folien über diesen Spiegel neu zu machen und riesen Reinungskosten haben, dann denke ich mir, lieber akzeptiere ich da so eine Kamera, zumal ich ja weiß, dass da eine Kamera drinne ist. Da ist so eine Kamera, die sieht man, oder ist ein Schild von der Videoüberwachung.
Findest du es wirklich nicht problematisch, dass irgendjemand, also meistens sind es Leute, die irgendwas zwischen 3 und 5 Euro in der Stunde verdienen und in solchen Überwachungszentralen sitzen, dass genau solche Leute ständig darüber informiert sind, wer bei dir zu Besuch kommt und geht und wann?
3 bis 5 Euro ist auch so eine Sache, da gibt es ja so einen Tarif, da könntest du einen Tarif noch nehmen, oder da könntest du diesen Mindestlohn nehmen, 3 bis 5 Euro ist natürlich nicht so der Tolle.
Das verdienen die, das heißt ihr Preis ist relativ niedrig, wenn man von ihnen vielleicht Informationen kaufen will. Darum geht es mir.
Ich glaube nicht, dass sie mit Informationen handeln, ich glaube auch nicht daran, dass sie da interessant ist. Wer mich besucht hat, zu welcher Uhrzeit, der mich besucht wird, einfach darum geht, was kostet es, den Fahrstuhl neu zu machen, und was kostet so eine Videokamera. Jetzt zahle ich Miete, und ich habe lieber eine Videokamera, im Fahrstuhl würde ich genau weiß, was da eine ist. Im Publikum halte ich nicht, wenn ich da eine Videokamera sehe, und dann pummel ich da auch nicht an mir herum, im Fahrstuhl, wenn ich weiß, was da eine Videokamera drin ist. Also ist ja keine heimische Überwachung.
Da steht da irgendwo ein Schild.
Frank, steht da ein Schild im Aufzug? So richtig, so Achtung, Videoüberwachung, oder was?
Ist in meinem Fahrstuhl nicht drin. Ich sehe davon aus, dass in meinem Fahrstuhl keine Kamera drin ist. Wenn sie heimlich eingebaut wird, eine Schwannerei. Würde ich auch nicht gut kennen. Aber so liegt es ja aus jetzt, aber von dem anderen Frank ist sie ja nicht heimlich eingebaut, und dann hängt sie ja offiziell da.
Hast du eine Ahnung, was ungefähr so ein Einbau und der Betrieb von so einer Videoanlage kostet?
Tja, die Argumentation ist natürlich... Ich bin sehr froh, dass du anrufst, weil du hast ja sozusagen jetzt hier mal einfach mal ehrlich deine Meinung gesagt. Schließt sich natürlich zwingend die Frage an, ob du glaubst, dass diese Videokameras denn irgendeine Wirkung haben, die du dir da wünscht, nämlich dass plötzlich kein Vandalismus mehr stattfindet.
Ja, auf alle Fälle. Also wenn ich da mit einer Sprechdose stehen würde und jetzt irgendwas anmalen würde, dann würde ich mir natürlich ein Fahrstuhl auswürfen, wo keine Videokamera drin ist, als ein Fahrstuhl, wo eine Videokamera drin ist.
Also die Studien, die bisher gemacht wurden, besonders an Kriminalitätsschwerpunkten, wo Kameras aufgestellt wurden, haben ergeben, dass sich die Kriminalität überhaupt nicht senkt, sondern dass diese Kriminalität nur verlagert wird. Also kannst du davon ausgehen, dass möglicherweise in deinem Fahrstuhl kein Vandalismus mehr stattfindet, aber dann findet der im Treppenhaus statt. Soll dann das Treppenhaus auch noch komplett videoüberwacht werden? Und dann vielleicht, wenn das Treppenhaus videoüberwacht ist, dann ist plötzlich deine Wohnungstür, an der rumgeschmiert wird. Möchtest du dann auch deine Wohnungstür überwacht haben?
Also ich denke schon, dass die Leute rechnen können, die sich so eine Kamera hinstellen. Weil ich denke schon, dass die dann auch einfach durchrechnen, was kostet es, wenn eine Kamera da steht, was kostet es dann mal einen neuen Fahrstuhl machen. Und wenn die sehen, Mensch, es ist ja statt dem Fahrstuhl das Treppenhaus geschmiert, dass sie dann die Kamera auch abnehmen, bzw. dass sie dann halt die Kamera mal in das Treppenhaus hinsetzen.
Oh, damit sie dann wieder im Fahrstuhl weitermachen können?
Nein, die können dann parallel abstehen, das ist kein Problem. Ich habe auch kein Problem im Treppenhaus, in der Kamera. Und ich hätte auch kein Problem, wenn da irgendwo über sich ein Hausmeister mit einer Security-Jacke an, da hin und wieder mal durch die Häuser durchgeht oder unten über den Stiefel drüber geht. Hätte ich überhaupt kein Problem mit, würde ich unter Umständen sehr gut finden. Das ist dann die andere Alternative zur Kamera, dass dann halt wirklich jemand da ist, der dann da hin und wieder mal durchläuft. Der Punkt, der mich stört bei der ganzen Videoüberwachung, ist, wenn nicht Trophänie gewesen wird. Wenn es dann halt in Schwerin auf einer Parkbank ist, wo ich dann da sitze und mich dann über Gott über die Welt unterhalte und nicht weiß, dass jemand mithört. Das würde ich herzu nicht gut sehen. So eine Zentralisierung der Daten ist natürlich auch abzulehnen. Das ist auch ganz klar. Aber an neurarischen Punkten, wenn da eine Kamera steht und wenn da halt um das Schild da ist, ja dieser Ort wird Video überwacht, habe ich da grundsätzlich erstmal überhaupt kein Problem.
Aber dann würdest du nur das finden, wenn da auch Mikrofone in den Fahrstühlen sind?
Wenn da ein Schild da ist, hier ist auch ein Mikrofon, dann hätte ich auch kein Problem.
Also mit anderen Warten im Fahrstuhl?
Ich unterhalte mich mit meiner Frau, oder da ist eine Kamera mit einem Mikrofon und da unterhalte ich mich mit meiner Frau, wenn ich über Bescheid bin, unterhalte ich mich und nicht da über Funk will ich den anderen mal angehen. Dann mache ich das halt zu Hause in meiner Wohnung.
Aber um das Problem endgültig zu lösen, das Problem Vandalismus, müsstest du lückenlos alles Video überwachen. Und damit wärst du auch noch einverstanden, wenn der einzige Raum, der nicht überwacht ist, deine eigene Wohnung wäre?
Ja, wenn die eigene Wohnung, wenn es da eine Sicherheit gibt, dass sie nicht überwacht ist, das ist ja oft fachlich, weil die kann ja durchaus auch überwacht werden.
Gehen wir mal davon aus, dass sie nicht überwacht wird.
Wenn sie nicht überwacht wird, hat sie kein Problem damit.
Das wären dann Zustände, die wären schlimmer als in der DDR.
War ja auch kein Problem in der DDR. Da hat sie dann die Knackt am Telefon, dann wussten wir, dann hat man das Thema nicht wechseln.
Na gut, aber du konntest wenigstens zu zweit über die Straße laufen, ohne dass du permanent dabei beobachtet wurdest.
Und vermutlich warst du auch kein Opfer, sonst würdest du das vielleicht nicht sagen.
Bei uns hat auch Opfer das Telefon nicht knapp. Man kann sich darauf einstellen. Wenn man es weiß, ist es eine Sache, man kann sich darauf einstellen. Und dann kann man damit leben. Wenn man es nicht weiß, diese ganze Heimischtour, wie ist diese Beispiel in Schwerin mit der Parkbank, das ist natürlich eine Katastrophe, so was geht vorne und hinten nicht.
Aber Frank, ernsthaft, wie lebst du damit, wenn du auf Schritt und Tritt überwacht wirst? Wenn jederzeit jemand weiß, mit wem du dich wo triffst, welche Wege du zurücklegst, worüber du möglicherweise sprichst.
Das ist jetzt die Frage, ob die Daten zentral verwalten oder dezentral verwalten. Und wenn die HOBO-EG weis, was in ihrem Haus loslässt, dann darfst du auch gut wissen, wann ich das Haus verlasse. Wenn ich das nicht verlasse, das wird dir sowieso nicht interessieren.
Also ich finde, meine Wohnungsbaugesellschaft geht da nichts an.
Wenn diese Daten weiterheben wären, jetzt nehmen wir mal den Fall. Das ist nicht realistisch, aber spinnen wir mal die ganzen Sachen weiter. Die Daten werden weiterheben, oder zum BKA oder sonst was.
Das ist ganz realistisch, oder?
Das ist ganz realistisch.
Was meinst du, wenn sie einen Verbrecher suchen, werden sie nicht auf diese Daten zugreifen?
Beste Beispiel dafür, dass es realistisch ist, ist, es gab mal einen mehr oder minder kleinen Bombenanschlag in Köln, in Deutz oder in Mühlheim war das, wo zufälligerweise eine illegal angebrachte Überwachungskamera, und zwar eine illegal angebrachte private Überwachungskamera, den Attentäter gefilmt hat. Dieses Bildmaterial ist genommen worden, um ihn zu ermitteln, obwohl es eigentlich gar nicht hätte genommen werden dürfen. Und alle anderen, die da vorbeigegangen sind, waren auch auf dem Video und waren auch erstmal verdächtig. Das heißt, du schließt aus, dass es Justizirrtümer gibt in diesem Land?
Naja, nicht nur Irrtümer. Wir haben ja momentan gerade den krassen Fall, der viel debattiert wird von diesem Murat Konas, der über vier Jahre...
Kannst du irgendwo ranfahren, Frank? Das Rauschen ist echt extrem. Ach so, okay, solange lass ich deinen Regler ein bisschen unten. Wenn du was sagst, dauert es ein bisschen, bis wir dich hören, okay?
Also, ich will nun mal auf... Ich weiß nicht, warum der Fall mir gerade einfällt, aber Murat Konas, also der Bremer, der so lange...
Der Bremer Taliban.
Der sogenannte Bremer Taliban, der so lange festgehalten wurde. Also, es hat sich ja im Prinzip herausgestellt, dass nur das Vorhandensein der Daten und die Zukunftsmöglichkeit auf seine Datensätze ihm diese viereinhalb Jahre ohne ein Gerichtsverfahren, ohne einen Anwalt, ohne Kontakt zur Außenwelt eingebracht haben. Also, das ist natürlich jetzt ein krasses Beispiel. Solche krassen Beispiele sind ja sehr selten. Gott sei Dank sehr selten. Zumindest solche, die bekannt werden.
Na gut, aber die Sicherheitsbehörden nehmen ja auch genau solche krassen Beispiele, die noch nicht passiert sind, um uns ihre Sicherheitsarchitekturen zu verkaufen. Also, das ist ja immer so diese Filmdrehbuche.
Also es geht halt eigentlich um die Frage, ich finde zumindest, dass es um die Frage geht, ob man noch was zu verbergen haben kann. Für dich ist es aber offenbar ganz gleichgültig. Also Hauptsache, also findest du denn, dass Vandalismus irgendwie so wichtig ist, dass er sie deinen Hausflur und sozusagen dein Privatleben damit mit überwachen?
Äh, ich sitze dich in den Büchern, ich kann dich durchrechnen. Ich kann keine Chance durchrechnen, was kostet eine Kamera, was kostet mein Fahrstuhl.
Nicht wegen der Kosten, sondern wegen deiner Privatheit.
Meine Privatheit hab ich in meinen vier Wänden. Und wenn ich weiß, da steht eine Kamera, dann weiß ich, aha Moment, jetzt bin ich im Moment nicht privat. Das selbe Problem habe ich doch, wenn ich mit jemand anderem zusammen im Fahrstuhl drinne bin, dann weiß ich, in dem Moment bin ich nicht privat. Nur, dass ich den anderen Menschen körperlich sehe. Ich weiß, wenn jetzt mein Nachbar oder ein Fremder mit mir zusammen im Fahrstuhl steht, weiß ich, ich kann mich mit meiner Frau nicht über irgendwelche intimen Sachen unterhalten.
Aber wenn derjenige vielleicht...
Jetzt steht eine Kamera vor mir. Das Prinzip ist doch genau dasselbe. Ich verknallte mir zwei Minuten, um irgendwelche Sachen mich zu unterhalten, die anderen Leute nicht ansehen. Und so ist natürlich dieses Schild, hier Kamera oder Videoüberwacht und die Voraussetzung ist, dass ich weiß, was da an der Kamera steht.
Aber dann stell dir mal das Szenario vor, was Holger meinte. Also nach deiner Argumentation gibt es ja keinen Grund dafür, warum nicht wirklich jeder Zentimeter außerhalb deiner Wohnung Videoüberwacht wird. Das heißt, du musst dir vorstellen, dein gesamter Tagesablauf, in dem Moment, wo du deine Haustür verlässt, hast du ständig jemand direkt an deiner Seite, der alles auf Papier notiert, was du sprichst und was du tust.
Das ist jetzt die Sache Zentralverwaltung, Dezentralverwaltung. Wenn es zweckgebunden ist, jetzt nur diese Daten für die HUGO-EG, das tippt nur die HUGO-EG an, ist das in Ordnung. Wenn ich an Bahnhöfen überwacht werde, wo eine hohe Gefahr besteht, mit Terrorismus oder Sandfahrt, auch wenn es jetzt Hogi-Spiel wird, finde ich es auch in Ordnung. Wenn das denn dafür dient, aha, wir wollen jetzt Terrorismus bekämpfen, in dem Moment, wo alle Daten zusammengeführt werden. Wenn denn wirklich so ein Protokoll ist, Mensch, der Franke ist früh um 7 Uhr gestanden, war dann da und da und da und ist abends um 9 Uhr schlafen gegangen, hat sich nicht die Zähne geputzt. In dem Moment, wo so ein Protokoll da ist, ist es natürlich eine Katastrophe, wo diese Daten zusammengeführt werden.
Woher willst du wissen, dass nicht genau das passiert?
Na, ich sehe es bei Fahrschüren in der HUGO-EG, sehe ich jetzt...
Nee, nee, nee, woher willst du wissen, dass nicht die HUGO-EG mit der Deutschen Bahn AG die Daten abgleicht?
Kann ich mir dazu und überhaupt nicht vorstellen. Ich kann es nicht wissen, okay, aber ich kann es mir dazu und überhaupt nicht vorstellen.
Es ist gut. Technisch ist es sicherlich nicht unbedingt ein Problem. Also wenn es digitale Daten sind, könnte man die sicher austauschen. Für Bedarfsträger, also Ermittlungsbehörden oder Geheimdienste, ist es sicherlich auch kein Problem. Aber mir scheint es dir, dass du zu sagen, auch ein Vertreter von den Menschen bist, die sagen, ok, wenn wir hier Vandalismus haben, was ja meiner Meinung nach kein so schlimmes Verbrechen ist, oder eben Terrorismus haben, dann nehme ich diese Verletzungen meiner Privatheit hin. Also nehme ich es in Kauf, dass ich sozusagen überwacht werde, weil mir ist die Verhinderung von Vandalismus oder Terrorismus wichtiger. Ist das richtig? Ah ja, du empfindest das gar nicht als Verletzung.
Ich finde diesen Terrorismus, das ist sowieso, wo ich spiele, okay, wenn da eine Kamera auf dem Bahnhof steht, dann nehme ich sie in Kauf. Diesen Vandalismus, okay, damit kann man unter Umständen auch leben. Wenn ich damit lebe, muss ich mehr Mieter bezahlen. Das ist ja die Kehrseite.
Also du glaubst, Vandalismus ist teurer als die Kameras?
Gehe ich von aus, weil ich denke, dass die Leute, die die Kameras in den Stödern nehmen, durchaus rechnen können. Also da gehe ich von aus.
Das ist leider nicht der Fall. Also man kann das bei besonders vielen öffentlichen Projekten sehen. Die Kosten für die Kamerasysteme und für die Menschen, die nachher die Bilder bewachen, ist weit höher. Bei der Polizei kann man das in mehreren Projekten sehen, an der Schule auch. Also die Kosten, die die Videokameras verursachen, sind teilweise deutlich höher, als wenn man mehr Lehrer einstellt, die die Schüler erziehen oder dergleichen. Also sind schon immens die Kosten.
Was ich so erschreckend finde, ist einfach auch der Umstand. Da ist Vandalismus und Vandalismus hat auch immer eine Ursache. Und was wir nicht machen, ist, wir arbeiten nicht an der Ursache. Auch, dass irgendwelche Schüler in die Schule gehen und Lehrer erschießen. Das hat eine Ursache. Das fällt auch nicht einfach vom Himmel. Das ist jetzt vielleicht ein sehr krasses Beispiel, aber wir tun immer so, als könnten wir, wenn wir denn nur dann alle am Eingang nach Waffen abtasten, verhindern, dass in Erfurt ein Massaker passiert.
Das ist ja vor allen Dingen auch so, die Kosten für die Videokameras, die den Vandalismus verhindern sollen, verhindern ja den Vandalismus nicht. Er verlagert sich nur. In der Regel wird die HOVO G auf den Kosten für den Vandalismus sitzen bleiben, weil er sich einfach nur verlagert. Und die HOVO G ist ja eine sehr große Lichtenberger Wohnungsbaugesellschaft. Die hat ja überall Häuser und die wird auf den Kosten sitzen. Die hat also doppelte Kosten am Ende.
Also ist ja dann nicht mehr dieses Problem.
Nein, du, weil du zahlst es.
Sondern dann ist das Problem, da hat sich irgendjemand da oben verrechnet.
Nicht die, du zahlst es, nicht die zahlen es, du zahlst es.
Sicher, ich zahle dann letztlich auch für den Fehler, den die da oben gemacht haben. Und dann werden wir auch sehen, dass es ein Fehler ist.
Eigentlich müsstest du da morgen mal vorbeigehen und denen ein paar auf die Finger hauen und sagen, jetzt sagt mir mal, was der Vandalismus kostet und jetzt sagt mir mal, was die Videoüberwachung kostet. Und jetzt weißt mir mal nach, dass die Videoüberwachungskosten den Vandalismus eindämmen.
Nein, man muss sie addieren.
Sie sollen erst mal nachweisen, dass es das eindämmt. Addieren ist zunächst nur eine Mutmaßung.
Also zumindest bei der Kriminalitätsbekämpfung und Videoüberwachung ist das schon klar bewiesen.
Es ist aber letztendlich ein anderes Thema, weil es nicht mehr daran geht, dass wir total überwacht werden. Und dass dann am Ende des Tages ein Protokoll steht, was hat der Mensch frühstimmert, was hat er mit, was hat er abends gemacht. Sondern es ist ein einfacheres Thema, die setzen blödsinnig Kameras ein und das rechnet sich unterm Strich nicht. Okay, wenn sie dann irgendwann einsehen, werden sie es auch wieder abschaffen. Das ist dann halt so ein Lernprozess. Das Problem ist ja wirklich dieses Tagesprotokoll, was hat er frühstimmert, was hat er mit, was hat er abends gemacht. Und das sehe ich einfach nicht gegeben bei einer Videokamera, die im Fahrstuhl hängt oder bei einer Videokamera, die im Bahnhof hängt, solange diese Daten nicht zusammengeführt werden. Und da gebe ich gerne ein Stück meiner Privatsphäre auf, wenn ich sage, dafür wird die Miete billiger. Dass sie dann nachher nicht billiger wird, weil die sich verrechnet haben, ist wieder eine ganz andere Sache. Und dass der Terrorismus denn nicht mehr auf dem Bahnhof stattfindet, weil da die Kamera hängen, sondern irgendwo anders stattfindet oder man halt trotz dem Bahnhof, unter anderen Bedingungen, weil die ganzen Novice-Halftröne Kameras sind auch wieder eine ganz andere Sache. Aber ich werde durchaus bereit da ein Stück meiner Privatsphäre, wenn ich weiß, ob ich das jetzt, also nicht irgendwo bedrohen werde, nicht irgendwo hinterrückstabgehört wäre, werde, wäre ich durchaus bereit dafür zu opfern, wenn es ein bisschen einen Vorteil geben würde.
Dankeschön. Jetzt haben wir ein paar Leute, die wegen Kameras anrufen, obwohl es ja eigentlich um die Big Brother Awards geht. Hören wir uns trotzdem an, was sie zu sagen haben, oder?
Hallo Jens.
Und zwar, ich wollte auch keinen jetzt vorschlagen, sondern weil ihr jetzt so lange über Wohnungsgesellschaften gesprochen habt, ist mir doch eingefallen, dass die Überwachung nicht nur über Kameras stattfinden muss, sondern zum Beispiel auch über die Wasserzähler.
Die würde ja sehr einfach...
Ah ja, die zogenden Wasserzähler.
Zeig mal ganz kurz.
Halt, halt, halt. Erstens nicht alle durcheinander. Zweitens erklären, worum es ihr geht.
Ja, darf ich das kurz erklären?
Ja, du sollst. Du musst.
Ja, okay.
Also früher oder normalerweise noch weit verbreitet, dass es ja so, dass jeder in einer Wohnung seinen eigenen Wasserzähler hat. Und ja, um das moderner und einfacher zu machen, damit die, um den Wasserstand zu ermitteln oder den Wasserverbrauch, müssen die halt nicht mehr in die Wohnung gehen, sondern das wird halt gleich digital in der Zentrale übermittelt.
Und da können die den Wasserverbrauch sogar in Echtzeit einsehen. Das heißt, die wissen dann anhand der Verbrauchswerte und der Zeit, in der sozusagen das Wasser verbraucht wurde, können die sehen, ob du gerade die Kloschwülung gedrückt hast für ein großes Geschäft, für ein kleines Geschäft, ob du gerade Mittag kocht oder ob du überhaupt da bist.
Wie viele Leute in deiner Wohnung leben?
Und alle möglichen Sachen.
Das heißt, Personen fährt mit Aufzug hoch, in der folgenden Stunde wird in einer definierten Wohnung doppelt so viel Wasser verbraucht, dann kann ich davon ausgehen, dass die Person diese Wohnung betreten hat.
Mal ganz kurz, hast du das irgendwo aufgeschrieben? Also ich bin gefragt, deswegen bist du ein bisschen irritiert, weil wir haben plötzlich, es ist gerade ein heißes Thema, weiß nicht warum. Also es gibt irgendwie gehäuft Anfragen, es wird irgendwie diskutiert und geguckt und so. Es scheint irgendwie gerade irgendwo, weiß nicht, kam es im Fernsehen oder irgendwas?
Also ich glaube, ich habe es vor einem Jahr, habe ich es mal im Fernsehen gesehen. Und das ist mir jetzt in dem Zusammenhang eingefallen.
Also ist es so, dass viele Geräte, vielleicht mal monatlich oder in bestimmten Zeitintervallen die Sachen übermitteln, die Daten, weil die Geräte sind ja in der Regel batteriebetrieben und die Batterie hält dann einfach zu kurze Spende, die dauernd senden würden. Da ist halt so eine kleine Lithium-Batterie drinne oder sowas und zumindestens bei diesen Heizkosten verteilen. Also das sind die Geräte, die an den Heizkörpern hängen und dann zentral an ein Empfangsgerät im Flur oder auf der Etage die Daten übermitteln. Da passiert das in bestimmten Zeitintervallen. Also wir hatten auch eine oder mehrere Anfragen, wo sich Leute Sorgen gemacht haben, dass der Strom, Gas, Heizungsverbrauch, Wasserverbrauch in Echtzeit quasi abgemessen werden. Das ist halt dieses Szenario mit der Handplantage oder sowas ungefähr, wo dann halt besonders viel Strom und Wasser...
Was macht man hier mit geklautem Strom?
Wo sich Leute also schon Gedanken gemacht haben, ob sie da jetzt fern überwacht werden können. Das war auch, muss ich auch sagen, vor 20 Jahren ein Horrorszenario, als das Kabelfernsehen eingeführt wurde und damit auch schon angekündigt wurde, dass es einen Rückkanal gibt für sogenannte Telemetrieanwendungen. Das ist also so eine typische Telemetrieanwendung, wo also Fernwirken, Fernablesen von Daten, wo dann also die zentrale Post bei den Leuten ins Wohnzimmer gucken kann und schauen, wer jetzt gerade die Klospülung betätigt hat oder den Herd angemacht hat. Da würde ich sagen, da kann ich jetzt nicht pauschal sagen, ne, das ist so nicht. Da müsste man sich jetzt wirklich mal die Geräte anschauen. Die sind natürlich noch unter ganz anderen Aspekten interessant, wie ihr euch vorstellen könnt, weil das ist auch eine relativ kleine Technik, die auch günstig gebaut werden muss. Da kann man bestimmt ein bisschen Spaß am Gerät haben.
Leicht manipulationsanfällig.
Und in dem Zusammenhang können natürlich auch Informationen darüber abfallen, wie oft diese Geräte senden, ob man da möglicherweise einen speziellen Modus einstellen kann, so einen sogenannten Echtzeitmodus oder so was.
Und im Zweifelsfall einfach mal dafür sorgen, dass die alte Schneider von nebenan drei Hektoliter am Tag verbraucht.
Interessant ist natürlich die Frage, was den Leuten lieber ist, ob sie quasi diese Geräte drin haben wollen, die dann irgendwann einmal pro Woche oder per Monat per Funk die Daten übermitteln an ein zentrales Gerät, oder ob man ein oder zwei Mal im Jahr irgendwie so einen komischen, jetzt mal ein bisschen gemein, so einen Dödel in seine Wohnung laufen lassen will, der dann da irgendwie diese Zählerstände abliest und notiert.
Das ist doch super, die fangen bei mir immer unten an, also das Gastzähler. Der Schornschneifer, der fängt immer unten an, kriegt bei jedem Tessin Kaffee. Und wenn er bei mir oben ist, ist er immer so am Zittern.
Also der letzte bei mir, der sah eigentlich auch ganz schnuckelig aus. Ich fand es jetzt nicht so unangenehm, dass der in meine Wohnung kam.
Also die Konstanze, die hätte auch eine Zeit, wenn ihr mit der Konstanze heute Abend noch...
Hey, das ist unser Hauptpreis.
Ich habe die Vorschläge immer aufgenommen.
Welche Wohnbaugesellschaft ist denn das? Oder werden die flächendeckend, so langsam aber sicher, verbaut?
Flächendeckend.
Also nehmen wir alle Wohnbaugesellschaften, alle Vermieter, pauschal, alle böse.
Wir können ja mal die Hersteller von den Geräten nehmen.
Überwachungsvermieter.
Kylie Minogue spielt live in Berlin.
Und ich geh hin.
Klingt gut.
Aber Kylie Minogue spielt live in Sydney. Und ich flieg hin.
Klingt irgendwie besser. Rucks macht's möglich und fliegt euch zu den besten Konzerten der Welt. U2 in Honolulu. Kylie Minogue in Sydney. Paul van Dyck in Miami. Blockparty und Panic at the Disco in Las Vegas. Die Black Eyed Peas und die Pussycat Dolls in Los Angeles. Alles live und alles weit, weit weg. Fritz bringt euch zu den besten Konzerten der Welt. Macht an und mit ab kommenden Montag. Immer nachmittags um 4.
Und das hört man um 2.15 Uhr.
Die Potsdamer Staatsanwaltschaft ermittelt gegen mehrere Bundeswehrsoldaten wegen Störung der Totenruhe. Sie sollen bei ihrem Einsatz in Afghanistan mit einem Totenschädel passiert haben. Entsprechende Fotos waren heute veröffentlicht worden. Politiker aller im Bundestag vertretenen Parteien äußerten sich entsetzt über die Tat. Vor der Küste des Libanon hat es offenbar einen Zwischenfall der deutschen Marine mit der israelischen Luftwaffe gegeben. Der Tagesspiegel berichtet, zwei israelische Kammflugzeuge hätten ein deutsches Schiff überflogen und zweimal in die Luft geschossen. Außerdem hätten die Piloten Infrarot-Täuschkörper zur Raketenabwehr abgefeuert. Der Vorfall wird nun untersucht. Die Wirtschaft hat begonnen, die bevorstehende Erhöhung der Mehrwertsteuer auf die Preise aufzuschlagen. Das belegt die Teuerungsrate für den Oktober. Nach vorläufigen Zahlen stiegen die Verbraucherpreise innerhalb nur eines Monats überraschend um 0, 2 Prozent, trotz gesunkener Spritpreise. Den Statistiken zufolge stiegen die Preise vor allem für Bekleidung, Schuhe und Tabak. Zum Sport. Herde BSC steht voraussichtlich im Achtelfinale des Fußball-DFB-Pokals. Der Berliner Bundesligist führte bei den Stuttgarter Kickers mit 2 zu 0, als die Partie abgebrochen wurde. Ein Linienrichter war in der 86. Minute offenbar von einem Bierbecher am Kopf getroffen wurden und wurde kurzzeitig bewusstlos. Die Entscheidung, wie der Spiel gewertet wird, fällt nun das DFB-Sportgericht. Die weiteren Ergebnisse der weiteren Partien. Osnabrück, Mönchengladbach 2 zu 1, Bayern München, Kasserslautern 1 zu 0, Aachen-Aue 4 zu 2, Paderborn-Nürnberg 1 zu 2, Essen-Frankfurt 1 zu 2, Duisburg-Leverkusen 3 zu 2. Und noch Basketball-Vizemeister Alper Berlin hat die Siegesserie in der Bundesliga fortgesetzt. In einem vorgezogenen Punktspiel bezwang Alper Neuling Paderborn Baskets mit 92 zu 77. In dieser Nacht Richtung Prägnitz aufkommende Bewölkung, aber kaum Regen.
Die Temperaturen liegen zwischen 7 und 12 Grad.
Morgen dann neben Wolkenfeldern heiter bis trocken. Also so ziemlich alles. 19 bis 24 Grad auf jeden Fall.
A 12, Läne Ring Richtung Frankfurt zwischen Fürstenwalde, Ost und Briesen.
Gibt es Gefahr durch ein Defekt des Fahrzeuges, das blockiert den Standstreifen. Und Achtung, dieses Fahrzeug ist unbeleuchtet. Ansonsten gute Fahrt.
Vielen Dank Matthias, 5 Minuten nach halb 12.
Ihr Fritz, wir haben jedes Wetter.
Fritz ist eine Produktion des RBB.
Und wenn im Radio 103, 2 dann Fritz im Cottbus.
Hier ist Chaosradio 118 mit Constanze, Frank und Holger. Unser Thema heute Abend sind die Big Brother Awards. Ihr seid eingeladen anzurufen unter 0331 70 97 110 und kundzutun, an wen ihr denn gerne mal ein Big Brother Award verliehen sehen würdet. Also ein Preis für Datenverbrecher, also für Leute, die mit Privatsphäre, mit Daten nicht nur sorglos, sondern gar verbrecherisch rücksichtslos umgehen. 0331 70 97 110. Oh, doch. Chaosradio 118 ist hier. Es geht um die Big Brother Awards. Vergangenen Freitag wurden sie verliehen. Ein Negativpreis für Datenverbrecher.
Datenkragen.
Datenkragen und Datendielerringe.
Datendielerringe, die Daten in szene-typischen Päckchen mit sich bringen. Ihr seid eingeladen anzurufen. 0331 70 97 110. Kund zu tun, wer eurer Meinung nach einen Big Brother Award verdient hat. Einen nachhängenden Anruf haben wir noch. Da geht es noch um Kameraüberwachung, weil wir vorhin gehört haben, dass die HOVO G ein Big Brother Award verdient hat. Die Wohnungsbaugesellschaft in Lichtenberg, die nämlich jetzt die Fahrstühle mit Kameras überwachen lassen will, um angeblich Vandalismus damit wegzukriegen, was ihr wohl gelingen wird, nämlich weg aus den Fahrstühlen. Ein wunderschönen. Hallo. Das letzte Wort zum Thema Kameras hast du jetzt. Mach mal es draus.
Ich fange erstmal ganz frech an. Konstanze, was weiblich ist, sollte öfters immer im Chaos-Weite sein.
Genau das habe ich eben auch zum Einbeinigen gesagt.
Oh, danke.
Und das Beste ist ja, Konstanze ist ja auch eine richtige Frau.
Ja, ich musste mir unbedingt erstmal ein Video von Google holen.
Du hast dich dabei schon filmen lassen, Konstanze? Achso, da gibt es ein Video von dir?
Ja, die Frau hat noch nicht Vorträge gehalten.
Ah, okay, vom Chaos-Kongress meinst du? Ah, okay, wusste ich nicht.
Und, wie findest du sie so?
Die muss aber wieder gut, wollen wir zum Thema zurückkommen?
Ich warte darauf, dass du vielleicht mal rot wirst, du wirst ja nicht mal rot, was ist denn, du bist so abgebrüht, die Weiber heutzutage.
Ey, jetzt sag mal auf.
Aber es ist endlich meine Frau, die auch was versteht von der Technik. Aber okay, das Thema, das mit den Kameras, obwohl ich euch eigentlich erst mal so ein bisschen, obwohl ich das Thema sehr verstehe, muss ich sagen, die meisten Kameras sind entweder nicht besetzt oder es sind Dummies, die sehr gut gemacht worden sind oder es sind Kameras, die einfach gar nicht aufzeichnen. Das sind sehr, sehr, sehr viele.
Ja, aber sie beeinflussen doch trotzdem mein Verhalten in der Öffentlichkeit.
Und woher weißt du das?
Ich komme aus dem Sicherheitsbereich. Darauf möchte ich nicht mehr eingehen, was ich da genau tue. Aber okay, das sei dahingestellt.
Wait, nein, nein, warte. Also da müssen wir schon mal nachfragen.
So billig kommst du uns jetzt nicht davon, mein Lieber.
Also kannst du wenigstens ungefähr beschreiben, was du da tust?
Sitzt du von einem Monitor oder baust du diese Kameras auf?
Ich bin Allrounder im Sicherheitsdienst und ich mache ja auch solche Spielereien, die man dann nachher nicht sieht. Also ich bin derjenige, der präpariert Gegenstände. Ich arbeite als Detektiv.
Du bist Thomas Magnum?
Nein.
Nicht?
Nein. Nein, also ich bin derjenige, der das halt kommerziell macht und auch schon sehr oft und sehr lange gemacht hat. Und ich brauche mir da also das, was du wirklich so 90 Prozent hast, kannst du fast nicht mehr auswerten, weil es einfach nur grottenschlechte Qualität ist.
Das ist noch ein anderes Argument dabei, dass gerade diese massenhafte Kameraüberwachung, die hat halt wirklich nur den negativen Effekt, dass die Bevölkerung eingeschüchtert wird, aber keinen wirklichen Nutzen. Also man erkennt den auf den Bildern noch, dass der Mensch irgendwie zwei Augen, eine Nase und Ohren hat. Das war es dann in der Regel aber auch schon, weil die Auflösung einfach viel zu schlecht ist. Aber eben, das ist ja noch das Schlimme dabei eigentlich, dass diese Kameras wirklich dann nur einschüchtern und nicht mal helfen.
Ja, aber dass ich sie einfach nur mega grauenhaft finde, ist, es gibt für die Betreiber einen, naja, wie soll man das jetzt nennen, einen positiven Effekt, sich für Kameras zu entscheiden. Und zwar, wenn die Vandalismus haben. Oder wenn die nur irgendwie sich hinsetzen und sagen, Mensch, wir haben zu viele Kosten, wir müssen sparen. Dann sagen die, wo können wir sparen? Und dann werden Menschen gefragt, so Sicherheitsunternehmer. Und dann stehen heiß die großen Chefs da und sagen, na ja, dann baut ihr bei uns Kameras für 10.000 oder für 100.000 ein. Und dann geht ihr zu eurer Versicherung, legt uns unser Gutschein auf den Tisch und sagen, hier, wir haben das installiert und schon rastert die Versicherung runter. Und dann sagen die meisten so, bitte was?
Das ist premium-senkend. Wir hatten die Diskussion beim Kongress, bei unserer Veranstaltung, dass wir auch lange und ganz viel diskutiert haben. Wir haben schon überlegt, ob wir quasi einen Sicherheitsaufschlag auf die Eintrittstickets draufschlagen, womit wir dann quasi die höhere Versicherungsprämie bezahlt hätten, wenn wir die Kameras abschalten. Genau. Und das wäre also mal ganz interessant gewesen, weil damit wäre diese Privatsphäre oder diese Schutz vor der Videokamera einfach greifbar in Geld wert gewesen. Also einfach 5 Euro kostet das, wenn du nicht gefilmt wirst hier auf der Veranstaltung. Und das ist interessant, weil dadurch gibt es wirklich um eine greifbare Diskussionsgröße überhaupt erst mal.
Ja, wenn man sich jetzt anguckt, die 99 Prozent, ich sage mal realistisch, ich denke mal 80 Prozent, die alleine überhaupt alle Aufgaben, die der private Sicherheitsdienst erledigt werden, aus solchen Situationen geboren, dass die Versicherung sagt, holt euch ein Sicherheitsdienst, und das wird billiger.
Dabei müssten es die Versicherer, die in der Regel sehr gute mathematische und statistische Abteilung haben, viel besser wissen. Aber sie verlagern damit zu sagen, das Problem von ihren versicherten Gebäuden woanders sind, das ist, was sie tun.
Aber das ist immer so ein Zwischendrin-Kampf. Deshalb gehen die Preise bei den Angestellten natürlich auch runter.
Bestenfalls werden die Kosten für den Vandalismus zum Beispiel oder eben für die, ja, was immer da anfällt, an Kosten auf die Gesellschaft übertragen, weil sie das aus den privaten Gebäuden, die versichert sind, in die öffentlichen Räume holen.
Aber das war ein guter Hinweis. Also das Wichtigste ist auch nochmal anzusprechen.
Vielen Dank.
Dass also, um zu wissen, wo kommt es unter anderem auch her. Und das ist eine Sache, das haben wir auch schon gelernt. Ich sag mal, das war von einer Einsicht her vielleicht sogar bitter für uns, aber das ist halt eine Sache, wo es uns dann tatsächlich betroffen hat. Und es war halt ganz klar, okay, entweder bezahlen wir halt mehr oder wir haben keine Kameras. Also, wir bezahlen mehr und haben keine Kameras.
Ein Bürger wird das machen, weil die stehen alle da und sagen sich alle, wir müssen alle sparen und naja, dann lass mich halt überwachen. Das größte Problem, das wir überhaupt haben, ist, dass wir den Leuten halt versuchen, klarzumachen, passen hoch, hier, da und da musst du was ändern. Aber es wird nichts aus dem ganzen Grunde, weil die Menschen sagen, nö, interessiert mich gar nicht, erstens habe ich keine Zeit, keine Lust und es ist alles egal.
Das Problem ist, damit müsste man eigentlich mal die Leute konfrontieren, die wirklich dann auch in die Fahrstühle gehen und da irgendwie die Wände vollsprühen oder die Scheiben zerkratzen. Und das stelle ich mir jetzt eine ganz spannende Diskussion vor, aber das ist halt natürlich auch nicht die Aufgabe.
Glaubst du wirklich, dass jemand, der die Wände vollsprüht und Scheiben zerkratzt, überhaupt so viel denken kann?
Und außerdem, das Vandalismus ist vorgezogen, sie finden immer ein gerade wirklich aktuelles Feindbild. Es geht doch nicht wirklich gegen Vandalismus.
Naja, das ist schon ein Faktor. Also, wenn du mal so irgendwie U-Bahnen, Busse anguckst, also ich glaube schon, dass das auch beträchtliche Schäden sind. Nur ist das vielleicht auch eine Sache, die möglicherweise in den Schuhen, also das ist ja schwierig, man muss ja wirklich ganz unten anfangen mit der Argumentation und Diskussion dabei.
Ja, aber was ist denn der Grund, warum die das überhaupt machen? Also ich hab mich mal... Ne, ich hab mich mal mit den Leuten auseinandergesetzt und hab mal gefragt, warum die sowas machen, weil ich halt in verschiedenen Diensten bin, wo sowas, wo man in solche Leute kommt. Die meisten machen es einfach nur als Fightback, also einfach, dass sie zurückschlagen wollen. Dass sie sagen, wir werden in dieser Gesellschaft nicht akzeptiert und unsere Kunst wird nicht akzeptiert. Wir hauen einfach zurück, weil wir können uns ja eh nicht wehren.
Da ist aber den Kamerasdrehenden aber diese Spirale ja immer weiter und immer schneller eigentlich, ne?
Ja, aber die wissen ganz genau, dass die Kameras entweder gerade nicht aufzeichnen oder so. Die sind sehr sehr gut informiert und das ist das Problem.
Aber diese Kameras glaube ich schon, dass sie auch Aggressionen schüren und deswegen eben diesen Teufelskreis noch weiter antreiben.
Also man kann jetzt zum Beispiel an den Berliner Straßenbahnen sehr gut sehen, die ja jetzt fast alle überwacht sind, oder auch in Hamburg, in der U-Bahn, wo ja auch überall Kameras sind. Es hat sich einfach nichts geändert von dem Analismus, weil natürlich die Täter wollen die Wände und die Sitzmöbel beschmieren und sie tun es einfach. Weil sie auch wissen, dass die Technik nichts hilft.
Ja, das ist doch das Problem.
Genau. Aber es ist ja schön, dass du das nochmal auf den Punkt gebracht hast.
Ja, was will man dagegen machen? Das ist die große philosophische Waage. Weil wir haben ja den Krieg verloren.
Na ja, du beziehst dich auf den Vortrag We Lost the War, den Frank und Rob auf dem letztjährigen Kongress gehalten haben. Ich würde das nur für die anderen höher vielleicht nochmal sagen. Man muss es eigentlich schon konstatieren in gewisser Weise. Wir haben jetzt halt ein neues Feld, wo wir kämpfen, nämlich die Wahlcomputer, wo wir mal hoffen, dass wir den Krieg vielleicht in dieser Schlacht mal nicht verlieren. Aber wenn man jetzt die letzten ein, zwei Jahre Revue passieren lässt, dann kann man schon sehr viele verlorene Schlachtfelder sehen. Also die Liste ist ja sehr lang. Bei der Videoüberwachung reden wir ja eigentlich schon so viele Jahre und trotzdem steigt die Anzahl der Kameras mit jedem Monat. Und wenn man einmal durch Berlin geht oder durch jede andere beliebige Großstadt, dann kann man diese Kameras kaum mehr zählen.
Ja, das Problem ist auch, dass sehr, sehr wenige Leute davon mitkriegen. Also ich habe diese Petition zum Beispiel wirklich nur auf der CCC-Seite gesehen.
Hast du das schon unterschrieben?
Ja, natürlich. Gleich, als ich sie gesehen habe. Aber das Problem ist, ich habe Leute von mir gefragt, die wissen da gar nichts von. Ich habe denen den Link dann zugeschickt und ach ja, guck ich mir mal an. Und dann lesen sie sich das durch und ach ja, kann man ja mal machen. Und wenn sie da ganz viel Lust und Zeit haben, dann machen sie das und es kriegt halt keiner mit.
Da sollten wir bei der Gelegenheit vielleicht nochmal auf die Petition hinweisen, wer nämlich auf www.ccc.de klickt. Der kann einen Link finden zu der Petition, die übrigens nicht bei Bundestag.de ist, sondern auf einem schottischen Server, also nicht wundern. Das ist schon eine offizielle Petition beim Bundestag. Und dann kann man so dem Inhalt der Petition zustimmen, die sich gegen den Einsatz von Wahlgeräten, also Wahlcomputern, richtet. Dann kann man mit unterzeichnen und wir wollen möglichst die 50.000 Stimmen erreichen, um eine direkte Anhörung zu schaffen.
Ja, das Problem, was ich hauptsächlich sehe, ist halt dieses Aufkratzen der Menschen. Die müssen das begreifen, aber das geht halt nicht. Also wenn mich schon jemand fragt, was machst du so abends?
Ja, ich höre Chaosradio so. Hä, was? In der Schule werden solche Sachen wie politische Wissenschaften oder Lebensgestaltung, Ethik, Religionskunde unterrichtet und ich finde, dass das ein ethisches Thema ist, über das wir gerade sprechen.
Auch im Informatikunterricht.
Es gehört in den Informatikunterricht, es gehört dann aber auch tatsächlich in den Politikunterricht. Also was nutzt es mir, wenn ich weiß, wie das der Honsche Wahlverfahren funktioniert, wenn ich hinterher nicht sicher sein kann, dass die Bestimmen vernünftig ausgezählt werden. Also da fängt das an und wahrscheinlich sogar noch früher.
Also ich bin da auch ganz deiner Meinung. Also ich sage eigentlich auch schon seit Jahren, dass die Sensibilisierung dafür der erste Schritt sein muss. Dass man den Leuten einfach klar macht, worum es hier geht und was sie zu verlieren haben.
Ja, das haben wir zum Beispiel auch auf der Demo versucht hier. Und ich habe da auch so ein bisschen was versucht beizustellen. Die Kameras, die bei dieser Aktion da zum Beispiel kamen oder die Speicheltests kamen von mir. Und das Problem war halt einfach, wenn ich mir angucke, wer da alles gekommen ist. Ich habe telefoniert wie ein Besoffener. Also ich habe stundenlang telefoniert, wahnsinnig Kohle aus dem Fenster geschmissen, aber nicht einer davon gekommen, weil es war jetzt wirklich nicht interessiert. Und genau das ist das Problem.
Das waren einfach nicht so viele Leute, wie du erwartet hast.
Ja genau, aber das Problem ist, das Bewusstsein ist nicht da. Jenseits Leute interessiert das nicht. Die versuchen halt zu sagen, wenn ich mich konform verhalte, habe ich Vorteile. Und das ist das Problem.
Also sie müssen begreifen, dass sie genau die nicht haben.
Das ist das Problem.
Wir arbeiten dran.
Ja, wir arbeiten dran, genau. Das hast du schon wieder schön gesagt.
Ja, was willst du machen? Danke schön. 0331 77 97 0 ist die Nummer der Fritzotline. Eigentlich und nicht nur eigentlich, sondern insgesamt und überhaupt würden wir ganz gerne von euch hören, wer in eurer Meinung nach einen Big Brother Award verdient hätte. Big Brother Award wird verliehen an Firmen, Behörden und Personen, die sich in schändlicher Weise nicht um Privatsphäre und Datenschutz gekümmert haben. Und angerufen hat der Christian. Hallo Christian.
Wer denn?
Premiere. Ja, mich hatte mal eine Frau angerufen und ich habe mir dann so ein Abo aufschwarzen lassen. Ja, sie wollte dann noch meine Bankverbindungen wissen.
Hast du ihr die gesagt?
Telefon und Internet mache ich wenn überhaupt nur sehr, sehr ungern. Ja, sie hatte mich dann immer ein bisschen getriezt und das Einste, was ich ihr gesagt habe, so in Neustadt die Reifeisenbank, der meinte so, ja, da wäre sie ja auch allerdings nicht in Neustadt. Ja, jedenfalls, wo ich dann das ganze Paket bekam, stand dann auf der Rechnung meine Bankverbindung mit drauf. Samt Kontonummer und Bankleitzahl und wenige Tage später haben sie das ja schon abgebucht gehabt.
Und du bist dir aber sehr sicher, dass du die nicht doch zufällig in einem Anflug von vielleicht kurzen Blackout, die du auch angesagt hast?
Nee, also am Telefon auf keinen Fall. Vielleicht hatte ich es mal im Internet irgendwo bei einer Rechnung angegeben, aber am Telefon da auf keinen Fall.
Aber warst du denn vorher schon mal der Kunde irgendwie? Nee, auch nicht.
Und du nimmst also an, sie haben sie beschafft, also Premiere hat die Bankverbindung von dir irgendwo her gekauft?
Denke ich mal. Ich war bei meiner Bank, da ich fragte, die haben wir natürlich so. Also zumindest haben sie nicht gesagt, ja, wir haben die weitergeben oder ja.
Wenn da abgebucht wurde, dann musst du ja eine Einzugsermächtigung erteilt haben.
Die haben einfach abgebucht.
Also kannst du aber zu deiner Bank gehen und sagen, dass du diese Überweisung nicht getätigt hast und nicht dafür unterschrieben hast?
Wir haben ja auch zurückbuchen lassen, aber trotzdem fand ich das schon sehr unverstehend, dass das überhaupt schon alt mitunter rechnen werden stand.
Das ist interessant. Also frag doch mal, Spaß und Zauber, genau bei der Bank nach, wo sie glauben, wo die es herhaben könnten. Das wäre mal interessant.
Ja, die meinten auch so, ob ich dort nicht irgendwo schon mal Internet oder eine andere Anführung über Telefonen oder so weiter eben habe.
Also ich vermute ja, ich würde ja doch vermuten, dass du mit denen vorher vielleicht schon eine Geschäftsbeziehung hast. Also Bankdaten zuzukaufen ist schon sehr ungewöhnlich. Als Fall hört man das nicht allzu häufig.
Ich überlege die ganze Zeit. Ich habe so einen ähnlichen Fall mal mit irgendeinem anderen Unternehmen gehört. Ich komme leider nicht mehr drauf, was es war.
Also mit Premiere selber auf jeden Fall noch nicht vielleicht Quelle oder irgendwelche anderen Versankthäuser oder so.
Nee, da ging es irgendwie entweder um Zeitschriften-Abo oder Telekom. Eins von beiden war es. Also nicht Deutsche Telekom, sondern Zeitschriften-Abo oder irgendeine Telco, die da auch mal Mist gebaut haben. Habe ich irgendwo mal gelesen. Aber ich weiß jetzt wirklich nicht mehr, wer es war.
Atlas Verlag oder was?
Also wenn dem so ist, ist der Premiere ganz sicher ein Kandidat.
Ja, vielleicht hat es jetzt noch jemand mitgekriegt und will das bestätigen oder widerlegen.
Vielleicht ruft da jemand vom Premiere an.
Das wäre natürlich nicht schlecht.
Ich weiß nicht, ob es noch mehr Leuten so jagen ist, aber das war sowieso sehr unverschämt mit dem ganzen Premiere. Die wollten sofort Geld und alles haben, das habe ich nachher wieder weggeschickt.
Das ist bei Paydee wie so.
Hast du den Blue Channel abonniert?
Das war bloß so ein Probeding, wenn ich diese dämliche Karte da aktiviert hätte, oder registriert hätte, dann wäre ich sofort Kunde gewesen, hätte gleich zahlen müssen, hätte ja nicht mehr zurückgeben können und so. Also normalerweise kann man das ja nicht benutzen, weil man dann sofort registriert ist.
Klar. Und du hast dann einfach zurückgeschickt.
Danke Christian.
Kein Problem.
Immer am letzten Mittwoch im Monat, nur nicht im Dezember, da gibt es das Chaos Radio mit dem Chaos Computer Club. Constanze, Frank und Holger sind im Studio. Die Big Brother Awards sind unser Thema und ihr seid eingeladen anzurufen unter 0331 70 97 110 und kundzutun, wer denn, eurer Meinung nach, noch ein Big Brother Award verdient hat, außer denen die vergangenen Freitag schon einen bekommen haben.
Der Big Brother Award 2006 in der Kategorie Politik 2 geht an die Innenministerkonferenz, vertreten durch deren Vorsitzenden und CSU-Innenminister des Freistaates Bayern, Dr. Günter Beckstein. Ja, die Innenministerkonferenz erhält den Preis für ihren Beschluss, eine gemeinsame Antiterrordatei einzurichten, die von allen bundesdeutschen Polizeien und allen 19 Geheimdiensten des Bundes und der Länder bestückt und genutzt werden soll. Diese Vernetzung führt zu einer verstärkten Verzahnung von Polizei- und Geheimdiensten, und zwar unter Missachtung des Verfassungsgebots einer strikten Trennung dieser beiden Arten von Sicherheitsschutz oder Staatsschutzbehörden.
In anderen Ländern ist das schon üblich, ne?
Wir hatten sowas auch mal in Deutschland.
Da hieß das Reichssicherheitshauptamt, die das verwaltet hat, oder?
Ja, und Zentralkartei.
Zentralkartei. Also im Dritten Reich war das üblich, das so zu machen, ne?
Ja, also vor allem, was ja auch ganz deutlich kritisiert wird, ist die Aufhebung der verfassungsmäßig gegebenen Trennung zwischen Polizei und Geheimdiensten.
Na gut, dann ändern wir die Verfassung.
Ja, die momentane Koalition hat ja eine verfassungsgebende Mehrheit.
Also das Interessante ist, dass Geheimdienste im Gegensatz zur Polizei ja schon vorab ermitteln können. Das heißt also, die Polizei darf immer erst anfangen, Daten zu sammeln, Ermittlungen anzustellen, wenn irgendwas passiert ist, wenn es einen konkreten Anlass gibt und Geheimdienste...
Also zumindest jedenfalls ein Verdacht.
Und es muss schon einen Anhaltspunkt geben. Und Geheimdienste sammeln einfach präventiv Daten. Das heißt also, die füttern kräftig diese Datenbank mit Sachen, die halt mit Geheimdienstmitteln bekannt geworden sind. Diese landen in dieser Datenbank. Und dann andere Behörden können auf diese Daten zugreifen. Es ist zwar auch eine Trennung vorgesehen. Man muss sich das so ein bisschen vorstellen, vielleicht wie ein großes Google, wo man also Sachen eingeben kann. Geburtsdatum, Name von einer Person. Und dann bekommt man einen Hinweis darauf, wo diese Daten gespeichert sind, in dieser Datenbank, bzw. also einen Verweis darauf. Und dann muss man eigentlich eine Anfrage stellen und nachweisen, dass man berechtigt ist. Es heißt aber so, in dem Gesetz, wo diese Datenbank beschlossen worden ist, wie sie gebaut werden soll, heißt es also, dass diese Auskunft auch umgehend und unkompliziert erteilt wird. Man kann also davon ausgehen, dass es also eine reine Abnicken ist, von der Möglichkeit, diese Daten auch im Volltext zu bekommen. Das heißt also, eine wirkliche Begrenzung, Beschränkung und Überprüfung der Berechtigung überhaupt ist da eigentlich nicht zu erwarten.
Bei dem Stichwort Überprüfung möchte ich vielleicht noch mal auf etwas hinweisen, was gerne unter den Tisch fällt. So eine Beschlüsse und insbesondere auch die für die Antiterror-Datei müssen evaluiert werden. Sprich, alle Maßnahmen, zum Beispiel auch den Autokatalog, also alle einzelnen Verordnungen im Autokatalog und die Gesetze müssen evaluiert werden. Das ist eigentlich in den letzten Jahren unterlassen worden. Das heißt, es findet nicht tatsächlich eine Evaluation statt, ob denn diese Gesetze auch Sinn machen.
Für so Doofe wie mich Evaluation, ich war nie auf der Uni. Evaluation heißt, gucken, ob es überhaupt funktioniert.
Ja, einfach mal überprüfen, ob die Ziele, die das Gesetz verfolgt, damit erreicht werden können. Also technisch und inhaltlich. Und diese Art von Evaluation findet immer weniger statt. Und gerade auch bei der Antiterror-Datei wäre das ganz dringend nötig, denn wir haben schon bei der Rasterfahndung ganz deutlich gesehen, dass das Ergebnis Null ist. Also die Bürgerrechte, die dadurch eingeschränkt wurden, sind ja klar geworden. Da gab es ja das Verfassungsgerichtsurteil. Aber hierbei würde ich auch einfach gerne mal evaluieren sehen, was damit eigentlich passieren muss. Und zwar findet die Evaluation nicht nur danach statt. Auch davor muss abgeschätzt werden, was diese Antiterror-Datei eigentlich bringen soll. Das würde ich doch gerne mal hören von einem Politiker.
Wer genau macht da denn seinen Job nicht?
Na ja, also normalerweise muss der Gesetzgeber die Evaluation in Auftrag geben. Der Bundestag hat ja so einen eigenen Dienst, so einen wissenschaftlichen Dienst, aber das machen auch Universitäten. Also klar ist, dass das auf jeden Fall überprüft werden muss.
Wissen wir, wer im Bundestag dafür verantwortlich ist? Welcher Ausschuss, welches Ministerium, dass man denen auf die Füße tritt?
Naja, das muss man natürlich im Einzelfall machen. Also für die Otto-Katalogie hat halt immer noch keine richtige Evaluation stattgefunden. Wir wissen also nicht, wie die vielen Einschränkungen der Bürgerrechte überhaupt wirken. Ebenso bei vielen anderen Gesetzen, die nach dem 11. September beschlossen wurden. Ich finde, hier muss erstmal was passieren, oder müssen wir das erstmal beweisen? Ja, das kann gut sein.
Weil die behaupten eine Wirkung, also sind sie nachweispflichtig?
Bei der Rastverhandlung war die Wirkung auch null.
Und wir haben ja gemerkt, die sogenannten Kofferbomber, also die Personen, die da aufgefallen sind, die wären auch niemals in so einer Datei gewesen, weil die einfach nie vorher in Erscheinung getreten sind.
Selbst wenn.
Ja, aber zum Beispiel, genau.
Selbst wenn, wer hätte daran gehindert, die Kofferbomben hinzuzustellen?
Eben, also eine Datei, das ist natürlich klar.
Ja, aber Börs, der Punkt, den Frank hier machen will, ist der, dass teilweise, wenn man sich das Konzept dieser Datenbanken oder dieser Gesetze ansieht, einem schon klar wird, dass das eigentlich nichts bringen kann, wo der Ziel der Terrorismusbekämpfung ist. Ich meine, wir haben in Deutschland kein Terrorismusproblem. Sie behaupten immer, wir hätten eins, wir haben hier de facto keins. Also das ist ja bisher immer bloß alles hysterische statt gekreische. Aber selbst wenn man mal annimmt, wir müssten hier präventiv agieren, dann sind die beschlossenen Gesetze und hier auch, insbesondere die Anti-Terror-Datei, komplett sinnfrei, wenn man sich das mal ansieht. Und deshalb kann es eigentlich auch keine Evaluierung geben, die beweist, dass diese Gesetze Sinn machen. Die würde ich jetzt wirklich dann mal gerne sehen von den Herren und Damen Politikern.
Da kannst du lange warten. 0331 77 91 10. Wem würdet ihr gerne einen Big Brother Award verleihen? Dixi?
Hallo. Hallo. Schönen guten Abend.
Hallo. Wer ist dein Kandidat?
Ja, also eigentlich würde ich dem Datenschutzgesetz den Big Brother Award geben.
Dem Bundesdatenschutzgesetz? Ach, Mensch, das ist ja mal eine gute Idee. Warum denn?
Ja, und zwar aus dem Erfangengrund, weil das ganze System hinten und vorne überhaupt nicht stimmt. Und man sollte es halt einfach mal ein bisschen anders angehen.
Mann, ich muss dir so zustimmen.
Im richtigen Leben. Ich sage jetzt einfach mal, irgendwas ist hin, dann schmeißt man es weg und kauft etwas Neues.
Ja, nur bei dem Bundesdatenschutzgesetz noch nicht.
Das hört sich jetzt vielleicht ein bisschen primitiv an, aber wir erweitern Gesetze, egal ob es jetzt das Bundesdatenschutzgesetz ist oder andere Gesetze, und haben im Endeffekt überhaupt gar keinen Überblick mehr darüber, was nun richtig, was nun falsch, was zeitgemäß, was nicht zeitgemäß ist.
Kannst du das ein bisschen konkretisieren für das Bundesdatenschutzgesetz? Was genau schmeckt dir denn da nicht?
Naja, zum Beispiel, also ich mache es mal an zwei Beispielen fest. Ich bin umgezogen vor ein paar Jahren und habe wirklich versucht, aufgrund dieses Umziehens kann ja mich keiner mehr nachvollziehen.
Du wolltest deine Adresse jetzt mal richtig schützen.
Richtig, genau. Telefonnummer geändert, Name geht nicht. Der Einzige, der hat ja wissen muss, ist das Landes-Einwohner-Abend. So, dachte ich, okay, jetzt setzt ihr dich hin und lässt erst mal alles so stehen und liegen, weil hat doch auch noch zu tun ja mit dem Bauen und so.
Nachsenderauftrag?
Wie bitte?
Gar nicht. Da kann man alles selber machen. Also der, den man haben will, den kann man immer noch Bescheid sagen, hier muss hin. Auch Sparkasse, sonst dergleichen nichts, gar nichts Bescheid. Keine Banken, nichts. Also wirklich das Einzige, was ich ja muss, ist das Ummelden. Ja, und jetzt frag ich mich, warum nach, das war noch nicht mal fünf Tage her, die ersten Briefe kamen von irgendwelchen Werbesachen, mit meinem Namen drauf, mit meiner richtigen Adresse, vor allen Dingen auch so eine Bemerkung, dass dann eben, was man beim LEA auch machen muss, Vorderhaus, erste Etage links oder sowas. Kann mir immer jemand erklären, wo da der Datenschutz ist. Irgendjemand vom LEA muss das ja weitergegeben haben.
Ah, okay, dann würdest du aber vielleicht den Big Brother Award doch eher dem Meldeamt geben wollen, anstatt...
Naja, aber die sind ja geschlagen von dem Bundesdatenschutz.
Also, die sollten sich ja an Gesetze halten, meinst du.
Das wären doch die ersten, oder?
Aber es steht doch nicht im Bundesdatenschutzgesetz, dass das Landeseinwohneramt keine Adressdaten weitergeben darf, oder?
Also es gibt noch mal eine extra gesetzliche Regelung. Zumindest in Sphere Berlin ist ja auch novelliert worden. Und es gibt jetzt übrigens noch erweiterte Einspruchsmöglichkeiten oder Widerspruchsmöglichkeiten gegen die Übermittlung. Es gibt, glaube ich, drei Möglichkeiten. Das eine ist an Adressbuchverlage, muss ich lügen. Das eine ist an politische Parteien. Und es gibt, glaube ich, noch eine dritte Kategorie, in der man jetzt auch einzeln widersprechen kann. Aber dass die Landeseinwohnerämter Adressen, sage ich mal, verscherbeln, das ist eigentlich nicht so übliche Praxis.
Ja, was heißt denn nicht so übliche Praxis?
Das wäre jetzt meine Frage gewesen.
Also auf legalem Wege ist das eigentlich nicht möglich.
So, jetzt frage ich mich, wo der illegale Wege herkommt, wenn das LEA sowas draußen hat.
Mir kauft der nicht die GEZ vom Landeseinwohner?
Ja, ja, da wollte ich gerade darauf zu sprechen kommen. Das Problem ist, dass die GEZ, da gab es auch eine Gesetzesänderung, sie haben nicht ohne Grund auch einen Lifetime-Award bekommen bei den Big Brother Awards. Also wirklich für andauerne permanente Verletzung des Datenschutzes.
Warum dürfen die das und die straft?
Da gibt es eine gesetzliche Regelung für, dass die Landeseinwohnerämter das an die GEZ übermitteln dürfen.
Also du hast insofern recht, als dass hier das Bundesdatenschutzgesetz mal ganz dringend novelliert werden muss, und zwar in Bezug darauf, dass hier mal Strafen verhängt werden sollten, und zwar richtige Strafen für die Leute, die Datenverbrechen nämlich begehen. Und hier krankt sowohl die Landesdatenschutzgesetze als auch die Bundesdatenschutzgesetze in jedem Fall. Also hier hast du auf jeden Fall recht. Also das große Loch im Meldeamt nehme ich auch an, ist die GEZ.
Das heißt, die GEZ verkauft die Daten weiter, die sie vorher gekriegt hat irgendwo?
Von wem hast du den Post bekommen? Also mit der Adresse drauf, das ist eine ganz verdächtige Sache, also mit dem Vorderhaus und sowas, Informationen.
Die GEZ hat mir ja auch gleich nach, weiß ich nicht.
Genau, also das ist üblich, die bekommen die Daten auf jeden Fall, und eben auch mit diesen Zusatzinformationen.
Aber woher hat jetzt der Gewinnspielanbieter beispielsweise, der Dixie irgendwas geschickt hat, die Adressdaten?
Da kann man nur spekulieren.
Das heißt, wir wissen nicht mit Sicherheit, dass die GEZ, warte Dixie, wir wissen also nicht mit Sicherheit, dass die GEZ die Dinger weiterverkauft? Das ist also kein offizieller Weg, der da passiert?
Offiziell ist es ganz sicherlich nicht. Also es gibt noch andere Datendecks. Wir wissen zum Beispiel von einigen Bürgerämtern, die offene Wählernnetze haben, die nicht gut geschützt sind. Man könnte auch Daten klauen. Es kann natürlich auch ein kriminelles Verhalten dahinterstecken. Das ist unklar. Aber die GEZ wird oft beschuldigt.
Ist es der GEZ gestattet, ihre Adressdaten weiter zu verkaufen?
Nein, nicht, die diese vom Melderein enthält. Auf keinen Fall. Das ist nicht legal.
Wenn es passiert, wäre es auch illegal.
Aber wie gesagt, die Strafen, die das Bundesdatenschutzgesetz fordert, sind keine. Es gibt überhaupt keine wirklichen Strafen, die dort verhängt werden. Das Gesetz stellt im Prinzip jede Behandlung von Daten unter Erlaubnis vorbehaltet. Das heißt, wenn man Daten sammeln will, dann muss man die Grundsätze, die in den Gesetzen festgeschrieben sind, erfüllen. Es ist nicht vorgesehen, dass man eine fette Geldstrafe zahlen muss für Datenverbrechen.
Und im Zweifelsfall holt man sich die Einwilligung des Betroffenen oder des Kunden?
Nachher auch.
Und macht es eben so, dass es der Kunde gar nicht gemerkt hat, worin er eingewilligt hat. Das ist auch ein großes Problem, dass einfach da viel zu lasche Regelungen existieren, was diese Einwilligung angeht. Das heißt, der Kunde hat in der Regel überhaupt keine Möglichkeit zu erblicken, in was habe ich da gerade eingewilligt.
Ich muss jetzt ehrlich sagen, ich bin ein relativ pragmatischer Mensch.
So weit, so gut.
Und? Ja, ich packe die Sachen eigentlich immer gleich an, die fehllaufen.
Und deswegen hast du dich beschwert.
Das heißt, nö, ja, das habe ich auch, aber das bringt mir nichts. Wir quatschen hier, ich sage jetzt einfach mal, ich finde das sehr schön, deswegen habe ich, ich bin selten einer, der anruft, ich höre lieber ja nicht zu, aber mir stand ja halt schon so dick, jetzt dachte ich, jetzt muss ich doch mal. Warum haut man den Leuten nicht einfach mal einen auf den Kopf? So wie du so schön gesagt hast, es müssen Strafen verhangen werden, die auch schmerzen, also die nicht bloß so, ich sag mal, aus der Haushaltskasse bezahlt werden.
Jetzt kann ich wieder meine Lieblingsantwort geben. Schreiben sie ihrem Abgeordneten. Es gibt Leute, die werden von dir in Parlamente gewählt, damit sie Gesetze machen. Letztlich bist du deren Boss, bzw. deren Arbeitgeber. Die haben dir zuzuhören, wenn du dahin gehst und sagst, du willst ein Gesetz geändert haben. Wenn du das oft genug, laut genug und mit vielen Leuten genug sagst, dann wird möglicherweise auch was passieren.
Also die Abgeordneten bekommen ja Briefe.
Das Problem ist, dass die Masse der Bevölkerung zu Hause sitzt und sagt, die da oben machen sowieso das, was sie wollen. Ich darf hier ja sowieso nichts sagen. Solange die anderen nichts tun, werde ich auch nichts tun. Und solange keiner was tut, wird auch nichts passieren und es wird sich nichts ändern.
Und genau das mache ich. Und wir hatten vor ein paar Monaten schon mal das Gespräch, wir beide, wo ich gesagt habe, 80 Prozent der Deutschen, die da draußen sitzen, sind einfach nur blöd, um immer auf einen Nenner zu bringen.
Ja, möglicherweise sind sie das.
Du, dafür brauchst du nicht unbedingt zwei Stunden. Es gibt durchaus Leute, die einen Abgeordneten schreiben und das in drei Wörtern formulieren, so was wie, das ist kacke. Oder das kriegen sie schon hin. Man muss nicht unbedingt einen seitenlangen Brief schreiben. Man kann aber seinen Protestausdruck verleihen.
Ja, und?
Schreib ihnen einfach, wir wählen sie nie wieder.
Da machen die sich gar nichts. Politik ist dummerweise ein unglaublich langwieriges Geschäft. Das funktioniert leider nicht instant. Ich wäre froh, wenn es so ginge, dann würde ich ganz viele Dinge abschaffen.
Lass jetzt mein zweites Beispiel erst mal fallen.
Ich will übrigens noch die Frage zu beantworten, warum die GEZ berechtigt ist, Daten von den Landes-Einwohnerämtern zu kriegen. Weil du verpflichtet bist, wenn du ein Rundfunkgerät hast, dafür Gebühren zu zahlen, aber leider Gottes nicht die Wahrheit sagst.
Das ist ja richtig, das mag ja auch sein. Und warum darf die SEK-Steuer noch erhoben werden?
Ja gut, warum darf die Salz-Steuer und die Glühbirn-Steuer und und und und?
Nein, ich meine jetzt, das sind doch Gesetze, also zum Beispiel diese SEK-Steuer ist doch von 1920.
Aber es ist ein Einkommen für den Staat, der doch nicht scheuert, wenn er darauf verzichten würde.
Weil die wurde erhoben, um die deutsche Kriegsplatte auszubauen. Haben wir noch eine?
Natürlich haben wir eigentlich das Grad von Syrien schon vergessen.
Ja, außerdem brauchen wir für den Frieden.
Aber genau. Aber wir knallen das Zeug immer noch raus.
Für die Sicherheit. Wir rauchen für die Sicherheit. Was war denn für die Gesundheit? Tanken. Tanken für die Gesundheit, rauchen für die Sicherheit.
Oder im Rahmen der Privatisierung der Senderanstalten, die sich mit Werbemitteln finanzieren.
Privatisierung Senderanstalten?
Na ja, hier Sat1, ATL, wie sie alle heißen.
Du meinst die privaten Sender?
Richtig. So, ja, dann wurde jetzt Ende der 90er Jahre, bzw. Anfang 2000, nachgezogen von den Öffentlich-Rechtlichen, dass die Werbezeiten dann verlängert werden dürfen. Ja, was wurde verändert an den GEZ-Debüren? Gar nichts. Nee, jetzt wollen sie es ja noch die fritzen, die nur über den Computer gucken bzw. hören.
Zu Recht?
Zu Unrecht eigentlich.
Warum zu Unrecht? Entschuldige, diese Leute nutzen das, was wir hier tun. Und das, was wir hier tun, kostet Geld. Und zwar viel Geld.
Das ist richtig, das weiß ich.
Und sie nutzen es und wollen dafür nicht zahlen. Und da argumentieren sie damit, dass sie das ja bei den Privaten für lau kriegen. Und da rollen sich mir die Fußnägel auf, weil es gibt keine privaten Talksendungen zum Beispiel.
Das ist ja wohl wahr. Na gut, das ist jetzt wieder ein anderes Thema.
Können wir uns die Münder drüber fusselig reden?
Ja, aber deinen Vorschlag, am Ende deinen Vorschlag, das Bundesdatenschutzgesetz aufzunehmen, finde ich sehr schön.
Vielleicht klappt es ja nächstes Jahr. Dann muss aber auch der Bundesdatenschutzbeauftragte da mal antanzen. Aber den Mumm hat er dann wahrscheinlich, obwohl...
Der hat ja mit der Gesetzgebung jetzt noch auch nichts zu tun.
Egal, einfach nur um ein Zeichen zu setzen. Richtig, genau so.
Ach, der Schar, der ist schon echt...
Der ist super, ich weiß.
Der ist schon super. Er hat nur einfach keine Macht.
Ich lad mir den mal, ich lad den mal montags in meine Sendung ein, den Schar.
Einfach mal um ein Signal zu setzen und zu sagen, hier, guck mal Kinder.
Guck mal Kinder, das gibt's auch. Und weiter geht's mit Tom, der ist ein Insider. Hallo Tom. Whistleblowing aus dem Hause Premiere.
Naja, nicht direkt, aber das ging mal darum.
Das klang aber gut.
Es ging einfach mal darum, dass zum Beispiel, was von gesagt wurde, dass die bestimmten Adressen, die meistens diese Anbieter dort haben, die über diese Calloutlines dort anrufen, das sind Listen, die die Firmen direkt bei unbekannten Anbietern kaufen. Und zwar massenweise.
Also jetzt bei Adresshändlern meinst du, ne?
Genau, und das ist halt die Frage, was vorhin gestellt wurde, wo die diese Adressen herkriegen. Weil ich hab halt persönlich selbst in so einem Callcenter gearbeitet und hab das so mitbekommen. Das sind wirklich Listen, wo hart genug steht, der komplette Name, Familienstand, Kontonummer, Bankleitzahl, alles drum und dran, bevor die Leute überhaupt noch was sagen.
Da steht Holger Klein hat Kontonummer FUBAR bei der Kreissparkasse Euskirchen.
Die Bankinformation sind da auch drin?
Ja, die sind komplett drin. Die Sache ist aber, um es legal zu machen, müssen wir die Kunden, oder muss ich persönlich, muss ich dann die Kunden fragen, ob sie mir die Bankkunden freiwillig geben. Erst dann wird das legal.
Und dann checkst du, ob das korrekt angegeben ist?
So ungefähr. Wir hatten zum Beispiel auch mal in unserem Call Center das Problem, das hat ein Kollege, der hat das verpeilt, hat ihn natürlich nicht gefragt, hat es natürlich in dem Moment nicht legalisiert, hat das aufgeschrieben und hat das Ding rausgeschickt. Nein, nein, wir haben ja damals was anderes verkauft. Aber in dem Moment, wo der Kunde gesagt hat, ne Jungs, hört mal zu, so geht das nicht, hat das Ding zurückgeschickt und hat uns eine Anzeige angedroht. Und das ist dementsprechend, weil es Ausgabe von nicht öffentlichen Informationen ist.
Aber hallo.
Also mich wundert es nicht sehr, weil ich mir vorstellen kann, dass man im Ausland sehr wohl solche, doch kommerziell sehr wertvollen Informationen kaufen kann. In Deutschland wird es sicherlich sehr schwierig, da Adresshändler aufzutreten.
Also, ja, das gibt eigentlich eine klare gesetzliche Regelung auch dafür, weil das sind Daten, die schon auch schutzwürdig sind. Also ganz klar, Bankverbindungen, das sind keine öffentlichen Daten, also die nicht aus frei verfügbaren Quellen verfügbar sind, erlangenbar sind. Insofern gibt es da schon eine klare Grenze eigentlich und dürfen eigentlich nicht landen.
Dann wollte ich noch mal was anderes dazu sagen, weil der Hörer von mir hat ja Bescheid gesagt, dass das halt abgebucht wurde, was er aber nicht so ganz okay fand. Als Sohn einer Bankerin kann ich dazu noch sagen, dass wenn er damit nicht einverstanden ist und sagt, dass er das nicht draufgegeben hat, kann er das von der Bank zurück buchen lassen.
Ja, haben wir eben auch schon gesagt.
Sobald er diese Informationen nicht persönlich selbst rausgibt, hat diese Firma kein Anrecht, irgendwas auszuziehen.
Es ist aber eigentlich gut, dass du es nochmal betontest, damit es vielleicht auch jedem Hörer nochmal klar wird.
Das war damals so eine Sache, wo man schon gemerkt hat, dass das alles nicht ganz legitim war. Wir haben so eine Liste zum Glück auch nur irgendwie ein oder zwei Mal gehabt, weil es damit ziemlich viel Ärger gab. Und die Sache ist halt, umso mehr Informationen daraus sind, umso teurer werden diese Listen halt.
Das heißt, die Kunden, die du anrufen machst, haben schon verärgert reagiert?
Die wussten ja nicht davon.
Ach so, du hast es denen ja nicht gesagt, ne?
Genau, ich habe es halt vor mir zu stehen gehabt. Natürlich muss man sich dann aber auch so clever anstellen und sich das natürlich nicht anmerken lassen.
So getan, als würdest du mitschreiben, aber hast du nur ein Häkchen dahinter gemacht, ne?
So ungefähr. Wie gesagt, da hat man halt bestimmte Sachen, die dann halt dort schon voreingetragen sind. Und der Familienstand, man fragt natürlich trotzdem mal, ob man verheiratet ist, obwohl es dann natürlich alles da steht.
Kann sich ja auch geändert haben, man möchte die Daten ja auch aktuell halten.
Das sind halt so Sachen, die dann auch teilweise reingefallen sind. Und wie geht es ihrem Mann oder ihrer Frau, in denen sie gesagt haben, seit zwei Wochen ist da nichts mehr.
Aber du musst fragen, und wie geht es ihrer Frau Simone, geborener Müller?
Sind sie Witwe Müller?
Wäre es darauf reingefallen, wenn jemand angerufen hätte und gesagt hätte, naja, die Daten haben sie ja da schon? Oder dann hätte sie wahrscheinlich Schauspielern wissen.
Das ist mal ein geiler Trick, aber das wissen sie doch schon.
Manche wissen aber schon oder überlegen schon nach dem Motto, wo man teilweise diese Informationen her hat. Das ist auch z.B. in vielen Merkungen. Früher wurde man nachgefragt oder hier ist Toma Pumperwo.
Tom, deine Verbindung bricht gerade zusammen. Drehen wir deinen Kopf.
So, Moment.
Ja, jetzt wieder gut.
Früher war es halt so, dass viel gesagt wurde, ja, hier ist Toma hier im Punkt und wir würden ihm gerne das und das verkaufen. Das hat er heute gar nicht mehr gemacht. Heute wird ja speziell nach direkten Personen gefragt, die auf diesen Listen stehen. Und darum hat man im ersten Moment nie diesen Moment, wo man denkt, okay, die wollen irgendwas andrehen. Im Moment geht es halt auf diese böse Schiene und ist halt das, was heutzutage viel gemacht wird.
Ich würde dich gerne noch was anderes fragen, wo du dazu sagen, jetzt als Insider da mal Auskunft gehen kannst. Kannst du ungefähr abschätzen, wie viel Prozent der Kunden, die du angehoben hast, am Anfang dich erst mal gefragt haben, wo du eigentlich die Nummer hier hast?
Das fragt eigentlich in dem Moment, sobald man einen seriösen Eindruck macht, fragt sich das gar keinen.
Keiner? Keiner?
Keiner nicht direkt.
Es gibt vielleicht, drehen wir es mal hoch, das sind vielleicht zwei, drei unter 100. Die Chance ist sehr gering.
Oh Mann, das finde ich jetzt aber echt erschreckend.
Was ich viel schlimmer finde, ist, bei mir ruft nie einer an.
Du hast schon einen Flag. Das ist der, der am Fernsehen über Datenschutz redet, der wird nicht angerufen. Natürlich. Schade.
Was sind das denn für feige Hunde?
Kommt alle ein und kommt unbewaffnet!
Vielleicht ist aber auch dein soziales Profiling oder dein Scoring zu niedrig, weil in deinem kleinen...
Ich wohne in Friedesheim, da kauft eh niemand was.
Ich wohne in Kreuzberg.
Oh Gott, Kreuzberg. Na, da kannst du doch nicht anerrufen werden.
Aber in einer Allee. Erstens, vielen Dank für deinen Anruf. Zweitens, bleib doch bitte mal dran. Ich stelle dich noch mal raus zum Einbeinigen. Der wird noch mal kurz mit dir was besprechen wollen.
Zum Einbeinigen?
Der Einbeinige ist der, der an der Hotline sitzt, wenn ich hier Sendungen mache. Der hat nur ein Bein. Der Arme. 0331 70 97 110. Wem würdet ihr denn gerne einen Big Brother Award verleihen, wenn ihr denn einen Big Brother Award verleihen dürftet?
Jens?
Ich weiß gar nicht, an wen ich das direkt verleihen sollte, aber es geht um die Zigarettenautomaten.
Mit Altersspeichern.
Ich zeige, ja. Jetzt komme ich, Achtung, dann hört doch einfach alle mit dem Raufen auf.
Okay, ich fange also nicht wieder an zu raufen, okay?
Also Zigarettenautomaten, also die Hersteller der Zigarettenautomaten.
Nein, Geldkarte ist das.
Also es ist ab dem 1.
Januar so, dass am Zigarettenautomaten nur noch mit Geldkarte legitimiert werden soll. Das heißt, jeder, der 16 ist, bekommt ja einen Ausweis, bekommt auch eine Karte bei der Sparkasse oder bei der Bank, ganz normal. Und da ist so ein Chip drauf. Und dieser Chip, der legitimiert ihn.
Da ist nämlich das Alter drauf gespeichert.
Und durch diese Speicherung des Alters meine ich jedenfalls, dass da ein Verstoß ist.
Ganz kurz, weißt du, ob das ein Alter ist oder sozusagen eine 01-Information, ob derjenige 16 ist, also eine Berechtigung hat?
Es ist völlig egal. Du brauchst nur eine Karte reinstecken, wo jemand, der eine Karte hat, der über 16 ist.
Ja, die Frage ist, ob der auf der Karte sozusagen das Alter, also quasi das Geburtsdatum, oder sonst gespeichert ist, oder ob da nur ein Häkchen gemacht ist bei Jahr ist 16.
Da bin ich mir eben nicht sicher.
Okay, werden wir recherchieren.
Ja, also diese Probleme haben wir jetzt schon öfter geschildert bekommen.
Es steht heute aktuell in der Tageszeitung, dass da keine Daten gespeichert werden. Das wäre auch noch schöner.
Geht direkt an die Krankenkassen.
Die Frage ist, gibt es dann eine Möglichkeit abzugleichen oder auf der Karte möglicherweise auch zu hinterlegen, hat folgende Marke gekauft?
Das wäre ja auch sexy.
Nicht nur hat folgende Marke gekauft, sondern hat überhaupt gekauft. Und wird dadurch vielleicht irgendwann mal bei der Krankenkasse heruntergestuft oder hochgestuft.
Ein Risikozuschlag.
Ja, aber man weiß schon, diese Zigarettenraucher, die wollen ja auch dauernd irgendwie teure Feuerzeuge und die neigen übrigens auch zu Kreuzfahrten. Da kann man dann entsprechend die Werbung platzieren.
Da können wir aber immer anrufen, oder? Dann kann man alles verkaufen.
Kunden, die lange OCB-Blättchen gekauft haben, haben auch gekauft.
Kaufen auch einen Bonk.
Das sind irgendwann Mailings von Coke-Dealern. So, hey, sie kiffen doch dann.
Man sagt ja, die Geldkarte hat nur eine Geldfunktion und so weiter, aber da sind doch schätzungsweise mehr Daten drauf, als man so denkt.
Ja, wir werden das auf jeden Fall mal recherchieren, was eigentlich die Information ist, die da abgespeichert ist. Wir haben das jetzt schon mehrfach gehört.
Vielleicht kann uns da jemand helfen, da hat es gerade griffbereit. Ansonsten übrigens gute Gelegenheit, Chaosradio at ccc.de für alle Sachen, die es jetzt hier noch nicht ins Telefon geschafft haben. Und ansonsten, es gibt auch noch ein Wiki zur Sendung. Wir waren diesmal ganz schlampig leider mit der Vorbereitung, aber vielleicht könnt ihr uns dabei helfen. Und außerdem...
Es ist ja ein Wiki.
Es ist ein Wiki, genau, das bedeutet, da könnt ihr einfach Sachen eintragen. Und wir haben auch noch ein zusätzliches Projekt oder ein Versuchsfeld, wo wir versuchen, die Aufzeichnung, also die Mitschnitte, die wir anbieten, auch entsprechend mit URLs zu hinterlegen. Das heißt also, dass wir da so eine Timeline machen. Das ist ein Wiki, bei uns ganz gut erklärt. Und da brauchen wir immer ganz viel Unterstützung. Und da will ich mich auch schon mal vorab bedanken bei allen Leuten, die da irgendwie fleißig mithelfen. Da geht es also darum, wenn man das auf einem Player abspielt, dass dann automatisch die URLs aufpoppen, die wir hier in der Sendung genannt haben, oder zu Themen und so was. Und das Ganze dann noch weiter anzureichern, also dass es nicht nur ein Audio-Mitschnitt ist, sondern komplett dann ist.
Und wenn ihr schon mal im Wiki rumklickt, dann müsst ihr ganz dringend auch nochmal auf www.ccc.de klicken, denn da ist die Petition gegen die Wahlgeräte. Weil wir doch die Wahlcomputer ganz dringend verhindern müssten, sollte man da seine Unterschrift drunter setzen. Wir brauchen da dringend noch ein paar Mitzeichner, um die 50.000 Quote zu erreichen.
Hast du schon unterschrieben, Jens? Hast du schon unterschrieben, Konstanze?
Natürlich, ich bin ziemlich weit unten in der Liste, Hanni.
Hanni, die hat mich Hanni genannt. Kinders, ich beende die Sendung jetzt. Ich hab mit Konstanze noch was vor. Frank, du kannst auch weitermachen. Was mit den Regeln kriegste hin. Jens, vielen Dank für deinen Anruf. Falls irgendjemand, es ergeht wirklich folgender Aufruf, falls irgendjemand gerade Bescheid weiß, über das, was auf der Geldkarte gespeichert ist und gespeichert werden kann, insbesondere von Zigarettenautomaten auch vielleicht zusätzlich draufgeschrieben werden kann, ruf doch mal an unter 0331 70 97 110 und wenn ihr einen Big Brother Award verleihen wollt, dann seid ihr sowieso genau hier richtig. 0331 70 97 110 Wer hätte denn eurer Meinung nach einen solchen Award verdient?
Am kommenden Mittwoch startet das Fritz Musikkino. Das ist was ganz Neues. Und weil das Fritz Musikkino ganz neu ist, startet das Fritz Musikkino mit was ganz Besonderem. Mit Seed und der absoluten Premiere ihrer DVD Seed Life. Ja, kann man jetzt hier nur hören. Wer es auch sehen will, muss vorbeikommen. Und wer vorbeikommen will, braucht Karten. Das Fritz-Musikkino. Der erste Abend mit Seed und der absoluten Premiere ihrer DVD Seed Life. Kommenden Mittwoch ab 20 Uhr im Kino Babylon Berlin Mitte.
Und das hört man. Um dreieinhalb eins.
Die Potsdamer Staatsanwaltschaft ermittelt gegen mehrere Bundeswehrsoldaten wegen Störung der Totenruhe. Sie sollen bei ihrem Einsatz in Afghanistan mit einem Totenschädel pulsiert haben. Entsprechende Fotos waren gestern veröffentlicht worden. Politiker aller im Bundestag vertretenen Parteien äußerten sich entsetzt über die Tat. SPD und Linksparteien Berlin haben sich bei ihren Koalitionsverhandlungen auf einen Einstieg in die Gemeinschaftsschule geeinigt. Dafür sollen bis 2011 für Modellprojekte rund 22 Millionen Euro bereitgestellt werden, sagte der Regierende Bürgermeister Wohlbereit am späten Abend. In den knapp 12-stündigen Verhandlungen vereinbarte Rot-Rot zudem, bis 2011 auch den 3-jährigen Kita-Besuch kostenlos zu gewähren. Die Wirtschaft hat begonnen, die bevorstehende Erhöhung der Mehrwertsteuer auf die Preise aufzuschlagen.
Das belegt die Teuerungsrate für Oktober.
Nach vorläufigen Zahlen stiegen die Verbraucherpreise innerhalb nur eines Monats überraschend um 0, 2 Prozent, trotz gesunkener Spritpreise. Den Statistikern zufolge stiegen die Preise vor allem für Bekleidung, Schuhe und Tabak. Noch zum Sport. Hertha BSC steht voraussichtlich im Achtelfinale des Fußball-DFB-Pokals. Der Plenum der Bundesligist führte bei den Stuttgarter Kickers mit 2 zu 0, als die Partie abgebrochen wurde. Anilin Richter war in der 86. Minute offenbar von einem Bierbecher am Kopf getroffen worden. Ach ja, diese Scherze und wurde kurzzeitig bewusstlos. Die Entscheidung, wie der Spiel gewertet wird, fällt nun des DFB Sportgericht. In dieser Nacht in der Prignisaufkommen der Bewölkung, aber kaum Regen, bei 7 bis 12 Grad. Und am Tag daneben Wolkenfeldern wird es heiter und trocken bei 19 bis 24 Grad. Da haben wir keine aktuellen Meldungen der Polizei. Wünschen natürlich weiter eine gute und unfallfreie Fahrt mit Fritz, einer Produktion des RBB.
Vielen Dank, Matthias.
Und nichts für Ungute.
Ja, bitte, verzeih bitte.
Was willst du sagen?
Kein Verkehr? Nicht mal im Hindukusch? 6 Minuten, nach halb 1.
Ach so, Fritz ist eine Produktion des RBB.
Und von dem Radio 100, 1? Dann Fritz in Eberswalde.
Der Big Brother Award 2006 in der Kategorie Wirtschaft geht an die Society for Worldwide Interbank Financial Telecommunication, SWIFT. Stellvertretend an die deutschen SWIFT Aufsichtsratsmitglieder Roland Boeff, Senior Vizepräsident Bayerische Hypo- und Vereinsbank und Wolfgang Gärtner, CIO Deutsche Bank AG für die Durchbrechung des Bankgeheimnisses durch die Übermittlung von Überweisungsdaten von SWIFT an US-Behörden.
Ja, hier ist das Chaosradio 118. Das Chaosradio 118 beschäftigt sich mit den Big Brother Awards, die am vergangenen Freitag verliehen worden sind. Ihr seid nach wie vor eingeladen anzurufen unter 0331 70 97 110 und anzusagen, wem ihr gerne einen Big Brother Award verleihen würdet. Die Deutsche Bank hat ihr schon eingekriegt jetzt.
Wir haben gerade gehört Werner Hülsmann, der die Laudatio für SWIFT, also für den Preis an die SWIFT, vorgetragen hat. SWIFT, muss man sich vorstellen, da habt ihr wahrscheinlich normalerweise recht wenig mit zu tun. Es ist ein internationales Bankennetzwerk, eine Verbindung der Banken. Wenn ihr eine Banküberweisung von einem Land zum anderen macht, also wenn ihr zum Beispiel von Deutschland nach Österreich oder von Deutschland in die USA Geld überweist, weil ihr keine Ahnung auf eBay was gekauft habt oder sonst wo, dann geht es über dieses sogenannte SWIFT-Netzwerk. Und das Problem dabei ist jetzt, dass einfach die SWIFT, das ist eine Genossenschaft, also im Prinzip die von verschiedenen, oder glaube ich sogar von allen Banken, die Mitglieder sind, auch getragen wird. Die haben halt einfach mal die gesamten Daten komplett an die US-Geheimdienste übermittelt. Und die dürfen da so ein bisschen drin wühlen und drin graben und sich mal ein bisschen was rauspicken. Und das Problem ist, das ist also wirklich ein ganz, ganz krasser Datenschutzverstoß. Also auch einer, der auch wirklich juristisch relevant ist. Weil einfach die Daten, die innerhalb Europas, die Überweisungen, die gemacht wurden, die hätten halt auch sowieso schon mal niemals in die USA gehen dürfen. Und außerdem gibt es sowieso auch keine Grundlage dafür, dem US-Geheimdienst da Daten zu geben.
Aber was nutzt das, dass es hochjustiziabel sein mag? Constanze hat ja schon gesagt, es gibt ja praktisch keine Strafen, die dazu erwarten.
Nein, hier ist der Problem eigentlich noch anders als bei dem Bundesdatenschutzgesetz, weil hier geht es ja um internationale Rechtsprobleme. Selbstverständlich hat die Bundesrepublik und schon gar nicht ein deutscher Bürger überhaupt keine Möglichkeiten. Das Problem ist hierbei ja auch, dass diese Zwift-System der einzige Anbieter für bestimmte Arten von Auslandszahlungen sind. Also man hat gar nicht die Möglichkeit, jetzt diesen Datenverbrecher zu umgehen, also ein anderes System zu wählen, das ist überhaupt nicht möglich. Also man muss, wenn man zum Beispiel ein Unternehmen ist oder auch ein einzelner Bürger, halt über diese Zwift-System seine Auslandsüberweisung machen.
Was helfen kann, ist bei der Bank immer nachfragen, wie ist das, ihr seid dafür verantwortlich. Ich habe dann und dann Überweisungen gemacht, irgendwo ins Ausland und ich bin mir ziemlich sicher, dass ihr dafür gesorgt habt, dass der US-Geheimdienst illegal meine Daten bekommen hat. Was sagt ihr denn dazu? Und das sollten noch mal mehr Leute machen, dafür gibt es auch Musterformulare. Ich glaube, die kann man bei netzpolitik.org, da sind die verlinkt. Da kann man die bekommen, wo man also quasi so einen Musterbrief hat, wo man sich bei seiner Bank zum einen Auskunft verlangen kann, ob das tatsächlich oder was mit diesen Daten passiert ist und sagen kann, dass man das absolut nicht gut heißt. Es ist ein bisschen schwierig, weil wir haben es, also Zwift-Netzwerke, die berufen sich da drauf, dass sie ja eigentlich legal gehandelt haben, weil es in den USA gibt es die Möglichkeit, dass also die Geheimdienste diese Daten anfordern. Das Problem ist aber, dass die Daten hier in Europa ja auch den europäischen Gesetzen oder den deutschen Gesetzen unterliegen und dann nicht einfach in den USA an die Behörden weitergegeben werden können, ohne dass jemand zugestimmt hat. Und das ist die ganz große Problematik dabei. Ja, ist ein bisschen eine abstrakte Sache, aber trotzdem war es uns auf jeden Fall auch ein Preis wert, weil das ist eine Sache, die auch größer in Erscheinung getreten ist und einfach ganz klar preiswürdig war.
Man sieht an diesem Beispiel Swift auch so toll, wie dreist hier vorgegangen wird. Also ich finde, da hat sich geradezu angeboten, hier diesen Preis zu vergeben.
Jo, jetzt hören wir noch einen. Der Big Brother Award in der Kategorie Technik im Jahr 2006 geht an die Philips GmbH, Abteilung Unterhaltungselektronik, vertreten durch deren Geschäftsführer Ronald D. Jung. Für die Vorgabe, dass CD-Brenner ihre eindeutige Seriennummer auf den Rolling-Schrauben schreiben und damit eine Rückverfolgbarkeit von Datenträgern zum Brenner ermöglichen. Mit der Einführung der beschreibbaren CDs und den dafür notwendigen Brennern wurde der sogenannte Orange Book Standard geschaffen. Dieses Dokument beschreibt die technischen Vorgänge und Eckdaten, wie eine beschreibbare CD und das dazugehörige Laufwerk auszusehen haben. Maßgeblich beteiligt war seinerzeit die Firma Philips Abteilung Unterhaltungselektronik. Diese hatte, so wird berichtet, dem Druck der Unterhaltungsindustrie nachgegeben und die eindeutige Kennzeichnung der gebrannten CDs in die Spezifikationen der Brenner eingebracht. Von nun an sollten alle neuen Geräte ihre weltweit eindeutige Seriennummer während des Brennvorgangs auf der CD hinterlassen. Jo, das heißt also, das was wir auch schon vor letztes Jahr bei den Farbkopierern bemängelt hatten, aufmerksame Big Brother Award-Verfolger wissen es, dass also Farbkopierer ihre Seriennummer auf jeder Kopie hinterlassen. Das ist also auch offensichtlich bei vielen CD-Brennern so, es ist nicht bei allen so. Es gibt aber von den Hersteller noch keine Angaben darüber, welches Gerät jetzt die Seriennummer drauf brennt. Ich habe bei mir zu Hause eine kleine Statistik gemacht und habe festgestellt, dass gerade viele ältere Musik-CDs, die ich mal von Freunden auch gebrannt bekommen habe, das ist ja absolut legal in Deutschland, muss man ganz klar sagen. Da sind tatsächlich auch diese IDs drauf. Es war ganz witzig mal zu sehen, wer mir eigentlich mal welche CD gebrannt hat. Insofern eine ganz heiße Sache, weil es sind Spuren, darüber werde ich nicht informiert, das sagt mir niemand, dass es so ist. Das ist eine relativ alte Sache. Es ist eigentlich schon lange bekannt, aber nicht wirklich so richtig bekannt. Es gibt auch sehr wenig Information im Netz darüber. Auch selbst die Firma Philips war auf Nachfrage sehr überrascht davon, dass dem so sei und wollte das erst mal intern recherchieren. Aber man kann es tatsächlich auch mit Programmen auslesen. Es gibt die Möglichkeit, es ist also nicht eine Sache, die nur irgendwo auf Papier versteckt ist, sondern es ist eine Sache, die real vorkommt.
Das scheint mir eigentlich auch ein Trend zu sein. Du hast es ja schon erwähnt, bei den Kopierern. Wir haben ja ein ähnliches Verfahren auch bei den Druckern. Also das da auch. Bei Farbdruckern. Und mir scheint es sozusagen so ein bisschen zu einem Trend zu sein, dass man einfach solche digitalen Codes verwendet, um Wege zurück zu verfolgen von Daten.
Also vor allem ist das ein vorauseilender Gehorsam. Es gibt ja keine gesetzliche Grundlage dafür. Es gibt keine Verpflichtung, diese Daten draufzuschreiben, sondern das machen einfach mal die Hersteller so, weil sie sich entweder weniger Stress im Nachhinein erwarten. Also Philipps natürlich, klar, da war die Unterhaltungsindustrie, hat da ganz klar Druck gemacht. Die haben gesagt, die LCD-Brenner, die müssen jetzt irgendwie rückverfolgbar sein, weil sonst gibt es zu viele Raubkopien davon. Wobei also die ganzen wirklichen problematischen Mengen an Raubkopien, die werden irgendwo professionell in Asien oder sonst wohergestellt.
Die nämlich auch Raubkopien sind. Also eine Privatkopie ist nämlich keine Raubkopie.
Richtig. Und da sind natürlich keine Seriennummern drauf. Und das, was ich zu Hause als Privatnutzer machen darf, nämlich wenn irgendwie ein Freund vorbeikommt und kopiert mir meine CD, solange dabei also kein kopierschutz, kein technisch wirksamer Kopierschutz überwunden wird, ist das auch absolut legal und auch durch die GEMA-Abgabe auf Brenner und Rohlingen gedeckt.
Einen Anruf haben wir noch. Ist der Stefan aus Berlin oder Stefan?
Ich wollte nur ganz kurz einen Kommentar zu Holgers Einschätzung der Datensammlung der GEZ geben. Mir geht nicht darum, dass ihr öffentlich-rechtlichen Anstalt nicht das Geld bekommen sollt für die guten Dinge, die ihr fabriziert, eindeutig. Aber der Punkt ist, und da setzt ja auch insgesamt die CCC-Philosophie an, Datensparsam haushalten.
Ich habe nicht gesagt, dass ich die Methoden der GEZ auch nur im Ansatz billigen würde. Wie willst du sonst die Gebühren erheben?
Also ich glaube, eine Steuer...
Nein, nein, nein, das kannst du nicht. Also das ist auch eine Diskussion, die sind weit weg. Warte kurz, wenn du eine Steuer erhebst, dann machst du die Verteilung der Gebühren abhängig vom guten Willen des jeweils Regierenden, weil der nämlich die Hand auf den Steuern hält. Du musst das Gebühren finanziert machen, ansonsten hast du italienische Verhältnisse und das kann niemand ernsthaft wollen. Das heißt, du musst irgendeine unabhängige, zumindest quasi unabhängige oder so weit wie möglich unabhängige Institutionen haben, die diese Gebühren einsammelt. So gesehen ist auch eine Gebühren-Einzug-Zentrale kein Problem. Die Methoden der Gebühren-Einzug-Zentrale, die sind mithin ein ganz großes Problem und fragwürdig, ja.
Ich weiß nicht, also warum soll es nicht möglich sein, wenn man das in dem Gesetz ausführlich festlegt, dass das Geld sozusagen nur für einen bestimmten Zweck, also es ist keine Steuer, sondern eine Abgabe natürlich, dann ist das eine Abgabe, ok. Aber dann meine ich eben als eine Abgabe. Durchaus möglich, durchaus möglich. Die einen sagen hier pro Haushalt, die anderen sagen pro Kopf oder sowas. Da müsste man das gerechteste Modell sich überlegen, aber warum diesen irrsinnig aufwendigen Apparat GEZ?
Aber irgendjemand muss es doch einziehen und verteilen.
Ja natürlich, aber die Art und Weise, wie es die GEZ macht...
Ich sage ja, die Methoden sind ja sicherlich diskussionswürdig, aber die Institution einer Gebühren-Einzug-Zentrale finde ich nicht. Weil irgendjemand muss es ja machen. Und ich möchte wirklich nicht, dass es die Finanzer-Übendämter machen. Wirklich nicht. Weil die unterstehen einer ganz anderen Gesetzgebung. Die unterstehen denjenigen, die regieren. Und auf die sollen wir gerade aufpassen.
Die unterstehen, die wir gewählt haben.
Wir, also die öffentlich-rechtlichen Medien, wir bekommen Geld dafür, dass wir denjenigen, die Macht ausüben, auf die Finger gucken. Ob wir das gut machen, zu viel machen, zu wenig machen, alles sehr englisch. Wir bekommen Geld dafür, dass wir es tun. Und wir müssen soweit wie möglich von diesen Leuten unabhängig sein. Wir haben da sowieso schon Probleme genug. Und wenn wir es aber denen auch noch überlassen, über die Verteilung der Geld dazu bestimmen, dann sind auf einmal so Sendungen wie die Kollegen vom Norddeutschen Rundfunk mit Panorama, die massiv dem Helmut Kohl auf den Keks gegangen sind, die werden dann auf einmal nicht mehr mit Geld bedacht und dann gibt es diese Sendungen nicht mehr und Helmut Kohl kann machen, was er will.
Ja, aber es ist doch heute schon so, dass die Ministerpräsidenten darüber diskutieren, wie viel Geld ihr mehr oder weniger bekommt. Also von daher denke ich, sie unterliegt da sowieso einer engen politischen Kontrolle, einer zugängenden vielen Stellen.
Nein, sie ist bisweilen fragwürdig eng, aber wir unterliegen keiner politischen Kontrolle, ansonsten wird es diese Sendung hier nicht geben.
Hast du dann vielleicht noch andere schlimme Datenkraken, über die wir hier reden können, weil die Gebührendebatte einfach ein anderes Schlachtfeld sind? Fallen dir denn noch schlimme Datenverbrecher ein?
Nein, ich hatte mich erst einmal nur dazu äußern wollen, weil ich glaube weiterhin an die Möglichkeit einer Abgabe, aber ich finde, dass das nicht so sehr auffällt.
Aber irgendjemand muss sie ja einziehen und verteilen.
Meinen Siegen, aber ich halte dieses System sozusagen, dass es dafür eine eigene Behörde geben muss, die noch zu jedem Einzelbeziehung aufnehmen muss. Also ich bin nicht davon überzeugt, dass das ein Fehler wäre, wenn es die Finanzämter machen würden.
Also ich bin mal gespannt, wo die Diskussion hingeht.
Ich auch. Ich glaube, die gibt es auch schon seit es die GZ gibt, oder?
Nee, leider nicht.
Nee.
Also es wird ja jetzt gerade auch eskaliert, also gerade durch diese Internetcomputer. Und es wird Zeit, zu diskutieren darüber.
Das in jedem Fall. Stefan, danke für deinen Anruf. Schönen Abend noch.
Der Big Brother Award 2006 in der Kategorie Verbraucherschutz geht an den GDV, Gesamtverband der deutschen Versicherungswirtschaft, und zwar vertreten durch seinen Präsidenten Dr. Bernhard Scharek, für die Warn- und Hinweisdateien der Versicherungswirtschaft, mit denen Versicherungen umfangreiche Daten von Millionen von Menschen in Deutschland nach geheim gehaltenen Kriterien ohne ausreichende rechtliche Grundlage und ohne Wissen der Betroffenen, Speichern, Austauschen weitergeben. Die im GDV organisierte Versicherungswirtschaft unterhält eine gemeinsame Warn- und Hinweisdatei namens Uni Wagnis. Die Datei dient nach Aussage der GDV zur Aufdeckung von Versicherungsbetrug. Tatsächlich ist sie eine schwarze Liste, in der alle Personen landen, die irgendeine angeschlossene Versicherung für ein schlechtes Risiko, das heißt für nicht so lukrative Kunden hält.
Tja, das ist sozusagen die Anti-Terror-Datei der Versicherungswirtschaft.
Also wer davon mal betroffen war...
Da steht drin, Constanze raucht, Holgi hat Übergewicht oder sowas. Oder was steht da drin?
Ne, hier geht es vor allen Dingen um zurückliegende Versicherungsfälle. Also was genau drin steht, ist ja unklar, hat ja Rena auch eben recht deutlich gesagt. Aber klar ist, dass es Betroffene gibt, also es gibt Opfer.
Aber es gibt doch Tausende von Leuten, die in Versicherungen arbeiten und irgendjemand muss doch da auch den Mumm haben, zu sagen, hier CCC...
Ja, es gibt doch Anhaltspunkte über den Inhalt dieser Dateien. Aber hier geht es ja darum, ob man den Kunden sagt, was da drin steht. Und das tun sie nicht. Also sie tun eigentlich überhaupt nicht kund. Sie tun nicht kund, dass sie diese Dateien führen.
Und das Problem ist, dass sogar auch Anfragen nach Kosten übernahmen. Also gar keine tatsächlichen Versicherungsfälle, sondern auch zum Beispiel Anfragen, ob eine Versicherung in einem bestimmten Rechtsschutzfall zum Beispiel übernehmen würde. Wenn man das zu häufig macht, dann kann man da also auch schon mit einem negativen Scoring belegt werden in dieser Datei.
Also und die Folge, wenn man also durch das Raster fällt, besteht einfach darin, dass man keine Versicherung mehr bekommt. Also gekennet hat in mehreren Fällen, wenn man zum Beispiel in einer Gegend wohnt, wo man dummerweise betroffen ist von besonders vielen Einbrüchen und man hat halt irgendwie im Jahr drei und hat eine Versicherung, dann hat man dann keine mehr. Und wenn man die Versicherung kündigt, wird man große Probleme haben, um einen anderen Versicherer zu finden. Dann kann man maximal einen ausländischen Hausratversicherer finden. Bei Unternehmen ist das Problem eigentlich sogar noch größer. Insbesondere Haftpflichtversicherungen für Unternehmen. Wenn man dort einmal gekündigt wird, hat man in Deutschland überhaupt keine Chance, von einem anderen Versicherer noch angenommen zu werden, weil man halt auf der Blacklist steht.
Ich begrüße am Telefon Lutz. Arbeitest du zufällig in der Versicherung? Ja. Du weißt, was da für Daten drinstehen in dieser Liste?
Perfekt. Na dann hau mal raus.
In erster Linie geht es vor allen Dingen um verschwiegende Vorerkrankungen. Das ist erstmal das Hauptaugen.
Private Krankenversicherung meinst du jetzt? Und Leben.
Weil so ist das eigentlich entstanden, mehr oder weniger, dass viele weit gemäß die Gesundheitsangaben gemacht haben, wurden abgelehnt und dann haben sie halt bei den Nächsten versucht und die verschwiegen in der Hoffnung, dass sie dann angenommen werden.
Habt ihr auch schon genetische Daten, die dort aufgenommen werden?
Nein.
Also keine Test-of-Erb-Krankheiten? Bist du ganz sicher?
Also in meinem Zustand ist das nicht vorgesehen.
Na ja, mir sind Fälle bekannt, aber das mag nicht bei allen so sein.
Aber ist es nicht ganz schön blöd von den Leuten, dass sie denn sowas nochmal machen? Also ich meine, damit muss man auch eigentlich rechnen, oder? Also weil es steht ja auch explizit so drinnen.
Nehmen Sie meinen erstgeborenen Sohn und mein Haus. Man unterschreibt ja alle mögliche.
Also bei privaten Krankenversicherungen unterschreibt man ja schon ziemlich klipp und klar. Das ist was anderes noch bei zum Beispiel Autoversicherungen oder bei hausratshaftlich Versicherungen.
Oder Lebensversicherungen, die ja auch betroffen sind.
Ja und das interessante ist dabei, dass ja auch nicht nur die Versicherungsnehmer oder die Interessenten da gespeichert werden, sondern natürlich auch zum Beispiel Zeugen von Verkehrsunfällen. Das heißt also, das ist eine sehr weitreichende Datei. Interessant ist übrigens auch, dass diese Daten gespeichert werden, obwohl der Vertrag gar nicht zustande gekommen ist. Also das ist natürlich auch noch eine interessante Aspekt. Das heißt also, das ist wirklich eine riesengroße Datei. Und vor allem, wenn diese Daten auch regelmäßig an alle Mitglieder übermittelt. Es ist also nicht so, dass also angefragt wird, sondern es gibt halt im Prinzip wirklich, die werden halt immer so auf Vorrat schon verteilt.
Wer kann denn da alles in Lutz, also wer kann denn jetzt alles, wenn ich mich bei euch versichere, in meine kranken Geschichte Einblick nehmen? Jeder Mitarbeiter?
Nein, da sind spezielle Mitarbeiter, die das Risiko beurteilen. Und entsprechend allerdings von allen Gesellschaften, die dem Verband unterliegen.
Werfen die so eine Art Scoring-Wert raus?
Das ist von Gesellschaft zu Gesellschaft verschieden.
Also ist der Preis schon berechtigt? Oder zumindestens, für dich natürlich ein bisschen schwierig zu sagen, aber zumindest die Begründung trifft schon zu, dass es eigentlich auch eine Liste ist von Kunden, die möglicherweise nicht erwünscht sind.
Wie siehst du deinen Arbeitgeber? Siehst du den zu sagen kritisch, wenn du jetzt als Privatmann antwortest?
Teils, teils, ich kenne beide Seiten.
Das heißt, du kennst auch viele Betrüger, die sozusagen nicht wissen, ausnutzen. Richtig. Würdest du aber meinen, dass zumindest die Kunden ein Recht darauf hätten, zu wissen, dass es diese Listen gibt?
Die größten Teils wissen es eigentlich, weil wer seine Arbeit richtig macht, weiß, wie die Kunden daraufhin was unterschreiben. Und dann kommt das im Prinzip unvergleichlich auch dazu, dass die Daten gespeichert werden und welche Daten gespeichert werden.
Aber auch, dass sie ausgetauscht werden zwischen den Versicherern? Ich meine, ich habe jetzt auch diverse Versicherungen. Ich könnte mich nicht erinnern, dass jemand mich mal darauf hingewiesen hätte. Also unabhängig davon, dass ich es weiß. Aber wenn man es nämlich weiß, achtet man eher darauf, ob man auch tatsächlich darauf hingewiesen wird. Meinst du, dass sie es echt in der Regel tun? Naja, das war nicht die Frage. Natürlich sollte so sein. Meinst du, sie tun es?
Ich denke nicht, nein.
Das ist auch meine Erfahrung eigentlich. Aber du siehst schon das Problem, dass man gegen Betrüger natürlich vorgeben muss. Hättest du eine Idee, wie man das datenschutzmäßig machen könnte, ohne dass man die Bürgerrechte so einschränkt? Hast du eine Idee?
In Anbetracht der Situation, dass die Menschen nicht ehrlich sind, wird es schwierig. Ich kenne aus eigener Erfahrung, wo todbringende Krankheiten verschwiegen werden. Dann gehen sie zu den nächsten Gesellschaften und wundern sich natürlich, ob es abgelehnt ist auf Grundwolle bei der Gesellschaft. In vielen Anträgen ist auch dieser Passus drin, der dann auch nicht wahrheitsgemäß beantwortet wird. Da kann sicher die Gesellschaft auf die vorvertragliche Anzeigepflichtverletzung berufen. Wurden Anträge abgelehnt oder schwer angenommen? Das wird ja dann auch wissentlich falsch interpretiert. Die Gesellschaften argumentieren halt, das ist ein Selbstschutz.
Das Problem ist eben, dass eine Solidargemeinschaft dann auch nur funktioniert, wenn sie auch wirklich transparent ist. Wenn jedes Mitglied der Solidargemeinschaft ehrlich ist und gleichzeitig aber auch der Sachwalter der Solidargemeinschaft, also das Versicherungsunternehmen selbst, nicht in erster Linie darauf erpicht, es einen Gewinn zu maximieren, also möglichst wenig Versicherungsfelder noch tatsächlich zu zahlen. Also das schaukelt sich dann auch hoch irgendwo.
Es geht hier aber nicht um die Solidargemeinschaft. Also bei privaten Versicherern mit Solidarität wirklich nichts zu tun. Damit sagst du ja eigentlich auch selbst.
Ja, stimmt.
Unterm Strich ist es aber auch trotzdem so, muss man ja auch mal von der anderen Seite argumentieren. Wenn ihr jetzt bei dieser Gesellschaft seid und es wird ein Risiko eingekauft, was jetzt ein schlechtes Risiko ist, wo von vornherein klar ist, das ist ein Kostenfaktor, den bezahlt ihr denn mit.
Du hast das Problem, es ist eine Solidargemeinschaft, die gleichzeitig keine Solidargemeinschaft sein kann, weil sie Gewinn anstrebt. Eigentlich funktioniert das gar nicht, also private Versicherung. Also jedenfalls nicht so, wie wir es gerne hätten.
Also ihr könnt das Problem natürlich verstehen, nichtsdestotrotz bleibt das Datenschutz rechtlichen Datenverbrechen. Und zwar auch noch eins, was wir den Kunden verschwiegen haben.
Aber ich habe noch ein anderes Beispiel, wie weit Datenschutz gehen kann. Ich muss mal zur Erinnerung, eine gute Bekannte von mir, die hat sich über bol.de ein Buch gekauft.
B-U-L meinst du?
Und dann später ist sie in die USA eingereist, hat Visum gehabt, alles drum und dran, wurde dort am Flughafen abgefertigt, unerwünschte Personen, Rückreise, alles drum und dran.
War das mit Atombomben oder war das Chemische?
Nein, die hat sich nur ein Buch über den Islam gekauft.
Gab es auch schon mal einen Fall mit einer Kollegin, die...
Ja, und Henry Rollins war mal betroffen.
Echt?
Erzählt er immer in seiner Bühnenshow.
Amazon-Wishlist sofort löschen. Lutz, danke für deinen Anruf, die Sendung ist zu Ende.
Alles klar.
Gute Nacht. Das war's Chaosradio 118, die Big Brother Awards, die vergangenen Freitag verliehen wurden, waren unser Thema.
Vielleicht noch Palim Palim, eine kurze Werbung.
Es gibt diese ganzen Sachen nochmal nachzulesen. Und zwar nachzulesen in unserem Wiki.
Ihr müsst noch ganz schnell auf www.wccc.de auf die Petition klicken.
Und das Schwarzbuch Datenschutz, wo nämlich die ganzen Preisträger der letzten Jahre nochmal gesammelt sind zum Nachlesen. Ganz bequem in der U-Bahn, im Bus, auf Klo, wo auch immer.
Und in der U-Bahn, im Bus, auf Klo oder wo auch immer. Falls ihr einen MP3-Player dabei habt, könnt ihr diese Sendung auch nochmal nachhören. Die gibt es nämlich als Podcast auf Chaosradio.ccc.de. Da gibt es sowieso alle Chaosradios als Podcast. Im Übrigen verweisen wir auf den Chaosradio Express. Ein Podcast, der zwischen den Jahren, also zwischen den letzten Mittwochen im Monat, ins Internet geschmissen wird, auf das ihr auch da nicht aufs Chaosradio verzichten müsst. Wenn ihr Kontakt mit uns aufnehmen wollt, dann könnt ihr das tun unter chaosradio.ccc.de. Wir hören uns wieder mit dem Chaosradio im letzten Mittwoch im November. Das ist der 29. November. Heute im Studio waren Constanze, Frank und Holger. Und vielen Dank, geneigte Höhende, für die Aufmerksamkeit.
Nö, das war's.
Tschüss im folgenden Night Flight mit Martin Petersdorf.